DevTools: State of the Union
2017.   State of the Union
2017.
State of the June 2017
with Paul Irish.
.
State of the Union with Paul
Irish
PAUL IRISH:  All right.  How
is it going?  Good morning.
All right.  Today I want to
share with you some of the stuff
we've been doing on the Chrome
DevTools team in the past year.
speak a moment for the Chrome
DevTools team, we have been --
is really to deliver you the
tools to enable you to be
productive.  Can I get the
speaker notes right over here on
the left side?  It's going to
be great.  It's even better.
The good words.  We will do it.
going to be good.  I'll
just dance.
Until -- all right, all right,
all right.  Are we good?
Uh-huh.  Uh-huh.  Uh-huh.right.
Can we come back to this
machine right quick?  This guy
right here?  Love it.  Love it.
All right.
So whoo.  Thank you.  Today I
want to share with you some of
the good stuff we've been doing
the last year on the DevTools
team, and to speak for the team
we want to enable you and equip
you with the tools to make you a
productive developer. means
powerful tooling to understand
and improve your application.
We want that experience to be
fun, too, and delightful.  So
today we're going to cover a few
things.  your scripts,
performance, auditing for
excellence and look at
Node.js and Headless.  We talk
off with debugging and console
ergonomics.  The console is part
of the core experience.  You
spent a lot of time there, so we
enjoy investing these work
flows, so these are a few things
we noticed that might need some
sprucing up a little bit.  So
the console, right?  I'm going
to show you object previews and
some new, improved autocomplete.
on previews, we'll show a
video.  This is an object and
exploring it and this is a bunch
of network requests.  It's an
array of objects and to hunt
around and find the one object
I'm looking for, it takes a bit
of work, right?  Same thing
here.  I'm clicking around.
just wondering, you know, maybe
that we could provide this a
little bit more proactively, and
so we're going to switch over
to what it looks like now.  this
object, open it up, and now
when you click on open it, so we
get the previews of all the
child objects immediately.  So
just instantly browse, and you
see all the subproperties, and
you're in a good state of
knowing immediately what's
happening inside the DL.  All
right.  So that subject
previews, and that's another
view of that.  On the left we've
got what it was last week, to
be honest, but in today's Chrome
canary, you see something more
like this.  So an array of
arrays, and now you get to see
exactly what is in there without
having to click in all the
time.  This is good stuff.
right.  Yeah.  I like it.  I
like it.  It's good.  All right.
going to show you some
autocomplete stuff.  I'm coming
over here to my machine, take a
sip of water.  We're going to
pop open to the console.  All
right.  So we're here in the
console, and I'll bring it in on
about blank solid page.  Now,
you're at the console, and you
like to type things.  We want to
make sure it's very fast for
you to get completions so that
you are able to do the work that
you want to do.  I'm going to
look at document and we'll look
at document.head, and now I want
to make sure that -- I want to
look at the child nodes, okay?
So I search over to child's
nodes. out, now, at this point
auto completion as I type it in
because we know what document
head is, right?  Then we reach a
point where we type in download
to zero, and we've done this
array access, right?  Now, when
we do dollar zero, then all of a
sudden the completions, they
used to completely fail.  So I'm
happy to report that now you
have a period where like no
problem, array access.  You got
the completions, too.  Now,
another one.  Let's say that you
have an object.  The object
looks maybe like this guy.  So
the properties have dashes, and
so you might know where I'm
going with this.  If -- I'll
switch this over.  If we take
this and now we run this in the
console, then classes.net, but I
can't because there's dashes,
right?  Not a problem.  Square
back to notation.  No big deal.
back will make sure you have
the key names right here, too.
So good stuff.  We can do a
little better.  You might be
more on the bleeding edge of
things and the new side.  So
let's take this object here of
classes, and we're going to make
it a map, all right?  We do map
equals new map and we're going
to use object at entries.  I
think this is ES7 even, so
objects at entries and new map.
create a map of the exact same
information.  Now we do map.get
and open up the pa REN, and
there are keys, too.  Making
sure you have all the data right
at your fingertips.  All right.
while we're in the console,
sometimes we spend a little bit
more time typing something out
than we actually thought.  We
create not just a one-liner and
we're like, there's some work to
do.  We'll type out this
function.  I call it a log.
just say args and we'll open up
the bracket.  I want to do a
function.  Do I hit shift enter
so it doesn't evaluate.  I don't
want it to error.  Don't worry
about it any.  We're going to
give you a new line and indent
and, you're in a good place.
Type in console 1 and do the arg
s and log it out and enter
again.  We know you're not done.
We close off the brace.  fix
the indentation and enter it one
more and evaluate it. right.
That's good.  Now we have a nice
multi--line console aware of
what's happening and is not
going to evaluate something
that's obviously incorrect.
this console, too, has some
upgrades.  Syntax highlighting.
not here a year ago.   other
text editor features.  I hit
command D and can do multiple
selections and change what I
need right there inside the
console.  All right.  this is
some of the cool stuff in the
console.  Thank you, thank you.
Now I'm going to switch gears a
little bit and talk about asing
NUS JavaScript, right?  Do you
write a lot of asynchronous
JavaScript?  Me too.  Do you use
Promises?  Yes, Promises all
the time.  What it be like if we
didn't have them.  nice, but on
the other hand, debugging
Promises, not as much fun
really, is it?  So I want to
talk a little bit about
async debugging and show it
with a trio of examples.  We
come back over here, and I like
the about blank page.  This is
good. I'm going to look at these
snippets.  Okay.  So here we
got a snippet here.  Zoom out
just a tad.  All right.  So this
snippet.  We start out with a
job.  A job runs, and we call a
process.  In the process we
logout a little bit and get some
data.  We print that.  It's
just logs.  We finish up, and I
got a debugger statement here so
that I break, right?
Synchronous execution flow,
we're good.  I'm going to run
this.  This is a snippet, so I
can click this button or hit
command enter, and we're good.
Well, we do have a reference
error, so we're not perfectly
good, but if I just put that in
there, then I think we're good.
Okay.  It was an unnecessary
adjustment.  No big deal.  We
look over the call stack.  Okay.
Call stack.  We start off at
anonymous at the substantiation
of the job function.  Process is
called and we go in and finish
and end up there.  This should
be straightforward, right?
We're good.  We're good.  All
right.   we have that other way,
we're going to take it up a
number of so we're going from
synchronous to asink,
A sync so we use async await.
Now we call job but we
introduced a little sleep
function, just delay a few
milliseconds.  Now inside a
process we log out, but we'll
sleep.  We'll go fetch a fan
icon and print out that result
and sleep a little more and
finish, okay?
Let's try that owl and run
that.  We pause.   difference
here is that we have the same
four call frames in the stack
and they're pointing them at the
same location, but in the
middle of this we have this
asynchronous hop, because going
from job over to this call point
in finish we had an
asynchronous operation.  process
all of these are asynchronous,
sleep, print, and sleep again,
right?  So this also works and
makes sense, but Promises, how I
think a few more of us these
days are doing async work, so
I'll switch over to that.  Same
basic approach, but with
processes inside the job we do
resolve and go over here and
inside process we have a Promise
resolve, sleep, fetch, get the
result, sleep, finish, right?
run that.  The call stack again
four call frames here, but two
asynchronous hops in there.  the
important thing here is that we
are able to show the history of
why we got here.   these are
kind of toy examples, but in the
real world things get a bit
more complex.  So this is a
slightly more real world stack.
This is just the immediate
stack of five synchronous call
frames, and it looks like
something coming from J query.
There's not a lot of context,
but if we have asynchronous
stacks enabled and have that
feature behind the call stack,
then it looks more like this.
Taller stack, but it gives us
much more context, so even at
the bottom you see this came
from an event handler into
submit handler and submit data.
I know even at the top it
doesn't really communicate much.
why this actually happened.
Right?  This is increasingly the
default look of stacks, and in
the browser we have many short
spurts of synchronous work held
together by asynchronous
operations.  So like set
time-out, request animation
frame, Promises, plenty of other
APIs and not mention reacts new
core algorithm fiber.  This is
designed to break up big chunks
of work into small chunks of
work.  The browser is
all about async any.  Just a
look at how this is in reality,
this is a view of all of the
async operations happening over
the course of a quarter of a
second, and we're taking all the
asynchronous operations and
rendering them as little arrows.
don't expect you to get a lot
out of this, but suffice it to
say it's busy.  There's a lot
going on.  DevTools is able to
track what is going on from one
call frame asynchronous hop over
to the next.  We think it's
imperative for the tools to
communicate why you arrived at a
specific call frame.  So to
pull this off, we had to do a
lot of work under the hood, so
we instrumented all of the
browser points where async any
emerges, the timers and rafts
and promises.  We work closely
with the team and we track all
the asynchronous execution hooks
so that we can from the
entirety of the program
execution way to the beginning
-- back to the beginning of the
page load.  In order to pull it
off and do it efficiently at
scale, we needed to do some
work, because we were really
driven to flip the switch on
this feature making it from
something that was like an often
checked box in the corner to
something that everyone should
just get for free all the time.
there's no reason to collect,
you know, expensive snapshots
from the VM, replay execution or
like switching into another
tool.  What this really means is
stopping at any point of your
program execution shows you the
complete asynchronous history of
how you got there.  It's right
there at your fingertips.
Okay. cool.  What does this
actually enable?  I'm going to
show you.  I have three new
features I'm going to show to
you, continue to point, inline
breakpoints and step into async.
to do that, we come back to the
same demos.
The synchronous one.  Place a
breakpoint here on line 8, and
we're just going to start the
execution.  We pause.  going to
hit step over, because I want to
work my way down, result, print
the result, okay?  At this
point I can inspect the result.
Okay.   Perfect.  This is a
common debugging scenario.   it
over to the asynchronous world.
So here I'll place the
breakpoint, I'll run, pause, and
now I step over. get a step
over, and this time all of this
work is asynchronous, but we're
still able to use the nice
convenience of stepover.  We
made that a synchronous
debugging experience feel like
it was synchronous.   step over,
so it works great with sync
code and with 088 sync, but we
often do this a lot of times,
either you step over or you'll
be like, you know what?  I'm
here on this log.   line, and I
want to jump down to this.  I
set a breakpoint right now and
play execution, you know, but it
happens a lot.  We wanted to
make sure there was a bit more
of a convenient shortcut for
this, so that's continued to
point.  Now if you're paused.
down the command key or control
key, and we're going to
highlight in blue a few
destinations inside this
function that are available for
you to just jump to.  So when
you click on one of these
destinations, we're going to
allow the execution to go
forward and pause you right
there.  So I'll do that.  I'll
just click on this print.  And
we just let the execution go
forward.  Now I'm paused here,
and, of course, I can just
inspect this response.  It's a
little bit of a convenience.
Now, Promises, okay.  I'll pause
here and step over and step
over again.  What do you think?
I mean, how do you feel about
me stepping over at this point?
It's like, yeah, what happens?
Well, we just jump to right the
end, and we're now exiting with
the return value of a promise.
None of this work has happened
yet.  what?  I don't know.  So
we don't have the power of async
await and the nice convenience
of step over, and that's not
going to work for us.  We want
to have this power. we actually
thought about this and figured
maybe there's another way we can
do this.  And that led us to
inline breakpoints.  So now --
what I really want is I really
just want to pause like here,
you know?  I want to see what
this result is.  I want to pause
here, so I'm just going to put
my breakpoint on 14.  We're
going to highlight a few areas
in that line where we can
actually pause.  So, you know
what?  That spot right there, I
turn that on and flip that one
off, and now when I go forward,
I start off there, and I
continue execution.  Now I pause
inside of that function, and
now I can inspect the result
like I want.  That's good.
That works. honest, if you use
promises as much as I am, you
will be doing this all the time.
again, we're like we could make
a little more of a convenience
function.  We want to pull this
off with a single gesture, so
I'll break.  Now this time I'll
hold down control or command
again, and now there's the blue
destinations, but there's green
destinations.  green means, I'm
going to step into this
asynchronous function, so this
time I'm going to step into this
result, print, result and now I
am paused inside of this
function and I can inspect the
result just like that.  So
single gesture or handling the
step into async. right, guys.
So there's a lot of stuff in the
asynchronous debugs, and I'm
really excited about it.  I know
that's a lot.  going to switch
gears a little bit and talk
about performance, okay?  Now
when we talk to our users and we
ask questions like, all right,
when you guys work on
performance, what sort of panels
do you use?  do you use?  Do
you use the profiles panel?
Time line panel?  Yes.  Good.
Network panel?  Yeah.
Obviously, there's a few things,
and admittedly the tools are a
little distributed.  We're
talking about browser
performance here where the
completion of a JavaScript file
downloading immediately leads to
main thread work, and it's
critical to see that connection.
the JavaScript finishes
executing, the browser
calculates the layout and sends
off pixels to the screen.  This
pipeline is very integrated, so
we knew we needed a single
integrated tool to visualize the
entire picture.  So that's led
us to the performance panel.
So I'm going to show you a
little bit of the performance
panel in action.  To do that,
come back to my browser, clear
those out.  We're just going to
look at the home page of Nest
just for fun.  open the
DevTools.  Now, this is the
performance panel.  have
screenshots enabled and that
seems good.  I want to capture a
profile of the reload of the
page, just the load.  So I'll
hit that one button, and what
we're going to do is capture the
entire thing, and we'll stop it
automatically whether the --
when the page is done loading.
So I have stuff on the screen.
Sure.  Up on the top is a little
overview and film strip.  I can
kind of drag my mouse along and
see screenshots on the page as
it loaded.  Go from just the
very top bar to a little bit
more, these images, the text.
Like I said, we want to see how
this worked, so I'll just zoom
in on everything up to, yeah,
where things start looking good.
Of course, the page load
starts with some network
requests.  So I'm going to open
up network and zoom in.  This is
our HTML and some JavaScript
and some style sheets and so on.
This JavaScript catches my
eye.  So the network connection
goes out waiting for the bytes,
and then it starts downloading
right here.  So it's
downloading, downloading,
downloading, all right?  What
happens when this file stops
downloading?  Well, stops
downloading right here, the main
thread gets it right here, and
then look at this.  thread.
Evaluate script web components
bundle.  Yeah.  makes sense.
Okay.  So it's a nice connection
between the network and the
main thread, so we see that work
there.  just going to look to
the right.  Okay.  We do it, and
some other things happen.  Soon
enough the browser calculates
what it's going to look like.
recalculates style and layout
and paint.  I imagine somewhere
around here it will shift these
pixeling to the screen.  So now
you can open up the frames
track, and in the frames track
we have just the screenshots of
what was happening on the page
just positioned exactly where it
actually happened, so now I can
see, well, this was when, yeah,
we got the top bar with the
little Nest logo at the top.
That's something.  I expected
more, to be honest. just scroll
to the right a little bit.
Okay, there we go.  now we got
these images, and then the text.
Okay.  The fact that the text
took a little more time, it
leads me to an idea.  I bet that
we're dealing with web fonts
here, and we're waiting for the
web fonts to download.   --
well, open up network.  Zoom out
a little bit. bet you that web
fonts just finished downloading,
so I zoom out and scroll over
here.  Well, yeah.  I spot them
here.  We have at least the WAF
files of light and regular and
these are just completed.  Once
they completed, then the browser
had a chance to recalculate the
style, which it needs to do,
and layout, and then we could
ship the frame.  We have this
nice integrated view from the
beginnings of network requests
to pixels on the screen.  Now,
some of you who might have used
the profile panel to do
JavaScript development, I want
to orient you with what we have
here.  My collapse again is the
network.  On the main thread
we're dealing with just over
time what is happening.  you
look for what consumed the most
time at an aggregate view,
right?  So we zoom out and open
up the bottom and the bottom up
view.  The bottom up view is a
summary of everything that took
time sorted by its own
self-time.  Here we can see,
well, there was some JavaScript
on the page that took a little
bit of time.  The function E,
yeah, not so -- he was a little
slow, I guess, and R also not so
fast.  So E and R, watch
yourself.  The other important
thing is you see this in
context.  The browser was doing
a bunch of other work, right?
It was compiling scripts and
laying it out and recalculates
style.  You get to understand
that maybe E isn't so bad after
all.  Maybe I need to make sure
I need to recalculate style a
little less or lay things out
less or make those take less
time.  Pro tip, fewer down
elements will help this one.
Anyways, that's a good, quick
look at the performance panel.
We hope you dig it.   did that.
The fastest code in the
browser, we're talking about
profiles, right?  The fastest
code is the code that never even
runs, and better yet, the
fastest code is the code that
isn't even downloaded.  So we're
thinking about that and
wondering, what if we could
provide you with a better view
of what is actually being used
in the page?  That's led us to
the coverage profiler.  I'm
going to give you a short video
of how this worked.  All right.
a little app that I made, and
we're going to scroll down to
the bottom and open up inside
the drawers menu, the coverage
panel.  At this point, we can
just hit record and start
collecting data.  We're going to
get instant data, especially
from our CSS, because we know
what's applying to the page
right now.  Here we actually
see, you know, all of the
selectors, and which selectors
have already matched the page.
that haven't are in red.  Now,
select focus, there's no
drop-down focused.  Let's try
it.  We're going to click in and
hit tab, and that red ruler
went to green.  Instant, live
updates here over in the
coverage panel. JavaScript is
also available now.  This is the
JavaScript file.  Half of it is
unused, which isn't great.  We
look down, and if there's a get
trips function, it's not
executed.  It feels like it
should be.  All right?  Well, we
could just try it out.  We're
going to select a schedule and
go from San Francisco down here
to Mountainview, and yeah.  All
right.  Drop down the 50% unused
to just 10% unused, which is
good.  You're making good use of
all the bytes.  So the coverage
profiler gives you this sort of
insight.  Armed with this data
you can go to town.  The red,
unused bytes, they are not your
friend.  They are not your
user's friend either.  Don't
send users red bytes.  Nobody
likes them.  Check it out, the
coverage profiler.  Then again
-- thanks, thanks.  Then again,
sometimes all the bytes that
you're running on a page are,
you know, not necessarily yours.
They're someone else's and
third-party code.  When you see
a big waterfall -- a network
waterfall of a big site, you're
like, a lot of stuff going on.
this?  This is, you know, a
challenge.  You should know
exactly what's happening on the
site and who it is.  So it's all
about attribution.  We thought
about this, and we have a new
feature to though you.  Try this
out in Chrome Canary now, and
it's third-party attribution.
command palette is a great place
to turn this on.  Command,
shift, P and type in third-party
and type in badges.  Flip this
on.  Once you have this on, you
go over to something like the
network panel.  Now next to the
network requests, we throw a
little badge next to it.  So
next to the file name we say
something like DC.  When you
click on DC, it's DoubleClick.
GA badge.  That's Google
Analytics.  We're doing this for
a lot of different third-party
code.  Ads, analytics, tracking,
all sorts of stuff.  This is
available in other places, too,
so in the console you have logs
or errors and you're like who is
this coming from?  VM script I
don't know.  That doesn't tell
me much.  We tag it there too
and put the badges in and find
out.  Also over in the time line
you can take that bottom-up
view and group it by product and
see, okay, it looks like
they're spending a lot of time
on my main thread.  It's cool,
yeah.   That is good.  All
right.  So let me come back
here.  Yeah, it's good.  We got
a good amount of data in here.
over 1400 different projects,
products, and that means over
5,000 domains that we're keeping
track of and showing.  The data
is just kind of built in there,
but we have a link report
mismatch.  anything looks fishy
to you, click it and report it
to us.  to make sure the data is
super useful to you and as
accurate as we can be.  We
covered debugging and
performance insights, but
there's other key actions in the
work flow, and we added some
features there.  I think you'll
like them.  Some good stuff.
one, cookie editing.  You can
view cookies for a while and not
edit cookies.  I know you're
excited about this one, yes.  a
long time coming.  We have
cookie editing, and we're good
now.  Okay, okay.  Next one is a
good one.  Change tracking.
often you get this case, right?
You're editing the CSS and
tweaking something.  You make a
bunch of changes.  At this point
you have it to where you want
it to look like.  You lost track
of the changes you made so down
in the drawer you can open it
up.  We give you a dif of all
the changes you made file by
file.  Yeah.  Thanks.
experiment as of today.  We'll
be turning it on in Canary by
defaults Monday.  let's do that.
Okay, good.  All right.
Screenshots.  yeah.  Check this
out.  So we're looking at the
Google store, right?  You want
to take a screenshot of the
page.  We use that command
power, command, shift P and type
in s the screenshot and
captures it and we can open it
up, boom, easy.  It's good and
it's been there for a little
bit.  I can do better.  We're
going to open up the device
menu, and we can do the same
thing there.  What I like to do
is I like to turn on the device
frame and get that nice art
around it.  Then you capture a
screenshot, and you have that
good look.  It looks good in
presentations, puppies and dogs
are alley impressed with that.
them.  There's one more that I
like even more.  The full-size
screenshot where you get the
full page, capture it and now
single ping, full resolution.
Yeah.  I'm right there with
you.  I'm right there with you.
All right.  There's one more.
I had to sneak it in. resolving.
Sometimes you put a breakpoint
on a page and change it around,
and all of a sudden it's not on
the line you meant for it to be
on, right?  That's kind of a
pain.  we'll do that here.  I
place this breakpoint and put it
on -- put the break points on
construct select.  Now I go in
my editor and move things around
and adding a log.  A comeback
that's there, but whether I
refresh, it's in the first run
function, different things, and
it's not where I left it.  No.
right.  Now, you'll see this
Canary, beta, and it's refresh.
keep the position.  We track
where that was, and even if you
change things around a little
bit, we make sure that the
breakpoint stays on the same
line.  All right.  Yeah, it's
good.  Not going to work all the
time.  If you completely change
things, we'll lose track, but
we're doing our best.  I wanted
to share with you one of my
favorite parts here.  It's good.
the past year and a half,
personally I've been working on
the Lighthouse Project.  is
great and gives you insight into
what's happening and
improvements to make, right?
It's available as a Chrome
extension, command line app, a
node module.  Access it in a
variety of ways, but we knew
there was value in having it
integrated into the work flow.
This is what it looks like with
the DevTools presentation.  We
look at core experiments as an
example.  Pop open the DevTools,
and we go to the audits panel.
It's refreshed a little bit.
We go down and run an audit.  We
do the full audit of
everything.   point we emulate a
next 5X and throttling network
and CPU to slow it down a little
more like a phone.  We're
looking at a lot of things.
looking at the load performance
and capturing a bunch of
different metrics.  at things
like accessible, how much it is
and all that, and then we get
the report in the DevTools.  A
few things going on with this
site.  went outside, and not so
good for them.  The HPS had some
good stuff.  In the performance
section, a flip strip and some
of the high-quality metrics you
might have heard about.  First
interactive and how those line
up against the screenshots and
other things like image
optimization.  We give you an
idea how much value you get out
of the recommendations.  You
don't have to guess and be like,
it wasn't that impactful.
Thank you, thank you.  I'll show
WRUNWRUN -- one more thing
while I'm at it.  I ran it on
the Google home page.  The
accessibility results were
interesting.  we're in DevTools,
when you cover over the Node
results, we highlight it over
there.  You can click through
and inspect it.  Do it again
with a Klor-Con TRAS, so now a
few things it looks like in the
fooder that don't hit the
Klor-Con TRAS  -- con TRAGS mark
and we see the actual elements
we talk about.  The integration
between the insight of
Lighthouse and DevTools together
brings a lot
of power.  I've saved a
developer favorite until
browsers, they enable you to
create automated tools that can
run in a variety of different
settings.  People do a lot of
things with this.  Text
extraction, screenshots and
performance testing, security
testing, unit testing.  Everyone
here, raise your hand if you
use a Headless browser of some
sort. of course.  A lot of
things.  WOOECH seen  -- we've
seen this happening for the
longest time, us on the Chrome
team want to provide a
contribution to that scenarios
and those work flows, and so
today we're happy to officially
announce the availability of
Chrome Headless.  Chrome
Headless works great on all iOS
s, Linux and Mac and windows and
works great in windows and
Chrome 60.  This enables quite a
bit.  There's a lot to come.
for instance, is on the way and
we're excited about this.  Right
now things are a little
low-level, and they will be
higher level APIs coming soon.
There's a big, flour richinging
developer community around
chrome Headless right now, and
it's prime API, which is the
DevTools protocol.  If you're
curious about this, check it
out.  There's a great blog post
from Eric about Chrome Headless
to get you started with how it
works and all the tools
available right now.  All right.
thing.  No JS.  Who here
develops with Node?  Yeah, yeah.
too.  There's a lot going on.
Last year -- a year ago here we
announced that Node.js could be
debugged and profiled with
DevTools.  We announced a pull
request that enable them -- pull
request is submitted when
you're like, we'll announce
that, because that's what we
got.  Soon enough, yes, the poor
request got merged into a
Node.js, and it shipped.  No
we're in a great place.  A lot
of us developers spend time in
the browser and in Node, and we
want to make sure that the
experience in debugs Node is
good.  I want to show you
improvements to the work flow we
made and to contrast it to
debugging two years ago is good.
so good.  All right.  I'll show
you a little bit of stuff here.
Okay.  Now, I'm actually just
going to be -- this is how I
debug Lighthouse when I work on
it.  I'll bring back open this
browser.  This one.  Yeah,
great.  Now, I'll do something
like this, this command, right?
and I'm going to run this
script but anyways, the
important thing is inspect
brick.  It says I'm going to
start inspection, and I want to
put a breakpoint on the very
beginning, okay?  Otherwise I'm
running Lighthouse.  First thing
is I hit enter.  The URL pops
out and you see this and you're
like okay, well, I guess I'll
copy and paste it.  You
certainly can, but there are
better ways.  One better way is
we can type in about inspect,
and we see this panel.  And the
best one here that I recommend
you clicking instead of this
shiny-looking guy is the
dedicated DevTools for Node.
this window is going to be
dedicated to just Node, so you
can see immediately we broke on
the program execution, and I
again, have all the power I
need.  I can continue to step in
and just go crazy.  So that's
good.  We can do a little bit
better.  All right.  Now, at
this time I'm thinking it would
be good if I didn't have to
remember that URL about inspect
every single time, and this
functionality was available to
me in a bit more of an immediate
place where I spend a lot of my
time.  Now I'm going to open up
DevTools.  When I run this
command again, I don't know if
you spotted this.  Right up next
to the inspect element icon is
a new one.  A little green Node
icon that snuck in there right
there.  We detected a debugle
node.  If you want to debug
that, we have you right here.
pop open that same dedicated
DevTools for Node window.  The
cool thing about this dedicated
window, I love this, is you
know, okay this works, and I'm
debugging and do what I need.
Okay, I found a bug, so now I
need to, you know, fix a bug.
I'm changing things. need to
like run it again, and so run it
again.  Because we have that
dedicated window, it's like,
hey, I'm right here.  I got you.
I'll pop right back open, so
it's always there and
connecting.  Even if you have to
restart Node, you have one
single window and that will take
care of you the entire time.
right.  So I have to stop there.
There we go.  Okay.  You guys
have made it.  We've covered a
lot.  We've covered a bunch of
new features in DevTools from
that great new experience with
object previews, the
autocomplete in the console and
all the asynchronous debugging
goodies and performance panel
coverage, third-party
attribution, Chrome Headless,
Node.  All sorts of good stuff.
If you like this kind of thing,
follow us on Twitter.  Great
docs updated regularly, and if
ever you have bugs, we
definitely want to know.  If you
have future requests, we want
to know.  Any feedback about
your work flow and the things
that work for you.  N
ewbug.CR.com is where you can
find us.  That's it from me.
guys very much.  I appreciate
it.  Applause )
Our next session will be past,
presents and future of Machine
Learning moderated by Diane
green.  This session will begin
at
9:30.
Please well an amazing panel of
AI experts moderated by Diane
Greene.
Hi, everybody. Diane Greene,
and I run Google's phenomenal
Cloud.  I'm on the board of
alpha bit and I'm proceeded to
be here moderating this panel of
just absolute leading experts,
leading researchers and experts
in artificial intelligence and
Machine Learning.  We're going
to structure our panel talking
about past, present and future,
closing with some personal
reflections on the industry and
our careers.  Before I do that,
I'm just going to quickly
introduce everybody.  First is
Francois B  and she's the
principal scientist at Google
and leading of speech
recognition at Google.
everybody
uses.
is Lee, and she's the chief
scientist of Google Cloud
bringing AI/ML to companies all
over the world.  Also head of
Stanford's AI lab and inventor
of the I am NAJ net challenge
that contributed to developments
and she's a champion of
S.T.E.M.AI and the founder of AI
for All.  Next is Fernando V
iegas, and she's a computational
designer.  She focused on the
scientific and collaborative
aspects of information
visualization, co-leads the big
picture data visualization
group.  She's part of Google
Brain and known for her
visualization-based artwork,
which is part of the permanent
collection of the museum of
modern art in New York.
And then let me introduce DAF
fee Color, who is the chief
computing officer at calico
labs, which is a part of
alphabit, working to give people
longer and healthier lives.
She spent 18 years at Stanford
and led the AI group there and
co-founded Coser
a for open online courses.
Daphne was one of the "Time"
magazine's most influential
people in 2012 and won a
MacArthur award and won a prize
for computing, she's a member of
the academies of arts and
sciences and engineering.  are
just some of the proof points of
her excellence.
So we'll start with a
historical perspective, and
Daphne, as one of the most
prominent and prolific authors
of Machine Learning research
papers, can you give us your
perspective on how we've
transitioned to Deep Learning?
I think the Deep Learning rev
NUGS  -- revolution is exciting
enabler in so many real world
problems, but that revolution
came out of an outgrowth of a
lot of Machine Learning research
that led up to it.  So prior to
Deep Learning, there were
probably about 10 or 15 years of
very hard work in developing
models that were maybe more
handcrafted that required a lot
more thought and prior
knowledge.  You really had to
think through the specifics of
the model and how it relates to
the domain.  When you don't have
a lot of data, you have to
replace that with a lot of human
intuition on how the model
ought to be constructed.  As
we've gotten more and more data
in certain domains, text and
images being, I think, the two
primary examples and speech, of
course, as well, we've started
to replace a lot of that need
for human insight with more and
more data that counterbalances
that.  techniques developed in
those 10 to 15 years are still
pivotal today, both in the
methods themselves.  Those
optimization algorithms
developed over the last 10 to 15
years are still a key component
of what enables Deep Learning
to be successful.  I think that
while we might like to think
that Big Data is at this point
the solution to everything, it's
a solution in certain domain
areas, but in others we still
are unfortunately are in the
medium or sometimes small data
regime.  There's still a need
for balancing human intuition
about the domain with the data
we're acquiring and coming up w
ith a model that incorporates
the best of both.  you.   also
get your perspective?  You run
the Stanford AI Lab, and your
image network was Seminole, and
now you -- now you look at
bringing AI to every company in
the world.  What is going on
with this transition?  Right.
Thank you, Diane.  Just a little
bit of a historical perspective
that AI in all sciences of
human civilization is actually a
very young field.  We're about
60 years old.  The very question
of the quest for intelligence
in my opinion is what's at the
root of AI's inspiration, and
that dates back since the
beginning of the dawn of
civilization.  So about 60 years
ago when machines started to
compute and calculate at that
time very simple arithmetics,
already thinkers like Alan
TURing challenged humanity with
the question, can machines
think?  Can machines have
intelligence?  About 60 years
ago leading scientist like
minimum SKI and John McCarthy
get together and really jump
started a field that today we
know as AI.  The AI that the
founding fathers saw was very
different technically 60 years
ago.  It was the same core
dreams, which is making machines
to learn, to reason, to think,
to perceive, to speak, to
communicate.  AI has gone
through several waves of
technical development from first
order logic to expert systems
to the early waves of Machine
Learning to today the Deep
Learning revolution.  I would
say the past 60 years I call it
the individual AI or AI
individual.  It's the 60 years
where as a field we laid the
foundation of the questions we
ask, the subfields that are
essential to AI's quest like
robotics, computer vision,
Natural Language processing,
speech processing, and so on.
the way we measure the progress,
understand our data, and
discovery the tool sets.  So
around 2010, around that time
thanks to the convergence of the
maturing of statistical Machine
Learning tools, the convergence
of Big Data brought to you by
the Internet and by the sensors
and the convergence of
computing, the Morse law carried
us to much better hardware.
three pillars came together and
lifted AI from the individual
stage into what I call the inviv
stage.  It's where AI is making
a real impact to the world.
It's just the beginning.  Every
single industry that is at Cloud
and Google we see is going
through a transformation because
of data, because of AI and
Machine Learning.  This is what
I see as the historical moment
that AI is going to impact and
TRNZ  transform the field.  I
want to say it's just the
beginning.   and the
technologies we have developed
in the field of AI is really the
first few drops of water in the
vast ocean of what AI can do.
We cannot overpromise this, but
there should be tremendous
excitement that we can do a lot
of more work to make this A I
invivo happen.  Companies put
VISHT YAL renditions in the
Cloud, and they use AI to do
things nobody ever thought was
possible.  AI is being used
everywhere.  Not just in the
Cloud.  So thank you.  If we
dive a little deeper, Francois,
you've been at the frontier of
speech recognition, and now in
application speech recognition
is becoming almost common place.
take us through that
transition?  Certainly.  I j
oined Google about 12 years ago,
and a bunch of us came with
this vision of doing something
useful and fun with speech
recognition.  Speech recognition
had been around for quite a
while.  All of us had some
background in the field, but we
we wanted to do something fun,
and that was hard because speech
wasn't the quality it is now.
started with fairly limited
products where the task of
recognizing what the person says
wasn't too, too complicated to
where we're just trying to push
the envelope a little bit but
not too much, right?  We needed
to bring it to a place where the
product was successful enough
that people would want to use
our applications and then we
could start, you know, folding
data into the models and keep it
writing from there.  So we
build what we called Google 4.1.
I don't remember if any of you
remember that, but it was a
phone application.  You would
call a number, and it said say
what city and state.  You would
say what you were interested in,
and then it would ask you about
the business that you were
interested in.  You would say
that name, and then it would
offer to connect you to that in
that city and state.  So, again,
picture that.  It's 12 years
ago, and there's no iPhone, no
Android phone, right?  All you
have is that flip phone that you
put to your ear.  So it was
very basic.  Fortunately,
leadership at Google was real
visionary about this technology
and really encouraged us to push
the boundaries as much as we
could.  successful with the
first application, but then the
iPhone and Android phone came, a
nd everything changed obviously.
Now there was visual feedback,
so we started to think about
other applications and that was
voice search, so Google search
by voice, and we started to do
dictation and having a little
microphone in every possible
entry point in your phone so you
could do everything with your
voice.  More recently we've
moved into trying to enable
speech recognition within your
home with devices like Google
Home because people are asking
for more and more tasks to be
fulfilled through voice, that
was a really good entry point
into the whole Assistant story
where instead of just enabling
you to do very small things with
your voice, now you can ask
questions and phrase them in
Natural Language and you can get
really Google to be your
Assistant without the
cumbersome, you know, physical
keyboard input.  Thank you.
you said you want Democrat
ized data Ville
visualization.  WLAR the needs
for that and how has that
evolved?  Yeah.  So I've started
-- I started working in data
visualization over ten years
ago, and when I did, it was much
different.  It was much harder
to do data visualization.
machines were not nearly as
good.  And there wasn't as much
data out there that was publicly
available.  That started to
change, and now we find
ourselves in an environment
where people are interacting
with data visualization sort of
everywhere.  It's really
exciting.  It's been amazing to
see like journalism take on data
visualization and talk about
really complex stories.  When
they talk about statistics, we
always joke that data
visualization is sort of the
gateway drug to statistics.
like you're doing statistics
without even noticing that you
are because we're just visually
so good at picking up patterns
and outliers and so forth.  Data
visualization has been on this
trend of becoming more Democrati
zed, and I really believe that
people have -- we have been
increasing people's ability to
take in data and numerous see,
and so data visualization has
had a role to play in that.  In
terms of AI, it's been really
interesting because we saw a
major jump when, you know, Jeff
Hinton and colleagues proposed
the first sort of blockbuster
visualization for AI.  TSNE.  a
technique that allows you -- one
of the big challenges with AI
and Machine Learning, these are
systems that work in very high
dimension al spaces, and those
are hard for us at humans to
understand.  So visualization is
one way to sort of peak and try
to understand what's happening
in these systems.  These
techniques, such as the one that
Jeff Hinton developed, allows
us to sort of understand how
things are clustering together,
what are the relationships
between different concepts, and
how these systems are sort of
resolving the data that they're
ingesting?  I would say that's a
major -- those major problem
and the beginning as she was
saying, I feel like we're in the
beginning of this relationship
between how visualization can
help AI.
Thank you.  we're going to
switch to a slightly more
technical set of answers to
what's going on in the present.
Francois, maybe we'll start
with you in talking about speech
recognition technologies and
what have the transitions been,
and what were the challenges and
what are they today?  How have
the challenges evolved?  Yeah,
sure.   is very complex, right?
It's difficult to recognize
what you're saying. one of us
has a different voice and
accent.  We speak in different
environments, so all of that
contributes to the richness of
the voice.  I think mostly for
that reason, speech recognition
has always been based on Machine
Learning.  hasn't been or not
much of an earlier phase that
wasn't Machine Learning-based.
It's just that the type of
Machine Learning has been
evolving over time.  We kept
making progress in the field for
the last three decades, but I
think one inflection point has
been the adoption of neural
networks.  has happened maybe
eight years ago or so.  Maybe a
little bit less.  But the early
research in speech recognition
using neural networks happened a
long time before.  There was a
lot of activity in the field.  a
lot of promising results,
however, there wasn't a compute
support to really make it
happen.  So no networks were
abandoned for a while, and
speech recognition kept
improving with basic methods and
whatnot.  And then when we
started to really involve deep
neural nets, it was bigger from
an engineering viewpoint.  We
had to deal with latency issues,
with size and training
capabilities and so on.  when
deep neural networks became a
reality when we launched them
whether we really had them in
production, that's opened the
path to a whole bunch of other
improvements, because now we
have the capability of having
that complex machinery there
behind the technology, and so we
could move very quickly from
one neural architecture to the
next. we started to look into
recurrent neural networks such
as STM, and we looked into con
VOE LUGSal NURT networks so CTC
based and modeling and new
implementations coming out.
Google Home we have the neural
beam forming.   happening is
that the move into the neural
network space has opened these
incredible capabilities for
innovating the core technology
that powers our systems and
keeps optimizing and, you know,
giving all of you in whichever
language you're speaking the
best possible accuracy we can.
Okay.  Neural nets for speech
recognition to neural nets for
extending lives and making us
healthier.  A fairly open-ended
question for you, Daphne.  Why
did Calico need one of the top
researchers in the world in
molecular biology and Machine
Learning as the chief computing
officer?  doing over there?
Many you may not know of Calico
because we've been under the
radar.  Calico is one of the
Alphabit companies out of
Google.  It aims to understand
the problem of aging and to help
people live longer and
healthier lives.  When you look
at aging, you realize that it's
actually the single largest risk
factor for death.  I know that
seems kind of funny when you
think about it, but it's true
for almost every disease that
happens after the age of 40.  As
you grow older, year after year
the risk for that disease
increases exponentially every
year, whether it be diabetes or
cardiovascular disease or
cancer.  All of these increase
expo NENTSally.  No one knows
where that is.  Why after year
of life after the age of 40 puts
us at an increased risk for
each disease?  In order to
understand that, we really need
to  study the biological system
that is exhibit aging at the
molecular level all the way
through the systems level and
figure out what it is that's
causing us to age, because, you
know, I don't think we'll live
forever.  Maybe we can live
longer and healthier by
interventions.  One of our
earliest scientists Cynthia
Kenyan who came over to Calico
showed with a single gene
mutation, you can extend the
life span by 30% to 50%, and not
only does the worm live longer,
but like a healthy, young worm
in terms of reproductsive health
and movement and so on.  Can we
do something like that to allow
humans to live healthier?  That
would be really cool, but in
order to do that we have
understanding we still need to
gain.  In order to do that, we
need to gather data about all
the age.  Yeast, worms, flies,
mice, humans age.  What do we
all have in common at the
molecular level?  Fortunately,
scientists have been able over
the last 20 years to devise a
whole slew of measurement
modalites that allow us to get
an understanding or at least
data regarding systems as they
age.  That includes things like
sequencing and microfluiditytics
at the low level and images all
the way through to things like
track devices that track
movement and allow us wearables
to track movement and see how
systems change as they age.  No
human being has the capability
to put together data at these
different modalities that range
all the way from subcellular to
entire human populations.  All
these different modalities that
include DNA and RNA and mass
spec and imaging and so on, all
the time scales from the
subcellular scales to the scales
from an entire human life span,
how do you put them together
for a coherent picture of what
makes us age and what
interventions are likely to be
the most successful to slow the
aging process and making it
better.   ability to interpret
the data and make use of it
really requires a true
partnership between the
scientists who are collecting
and getting untuitions about
these processes and the Machine
Learning people who can help
construct models that can
synthesize and put it together.
Neither of these communities
can be successful on its own.  I
was one of the fortunate people
that entered the field in its
very early stages.  I work in
the field of computation
alibiology since the early 2000
s.  You can say that I'm native
in the language of Machine
Learning.  You can say that I
have a fluency in the biological
language, and as such it allows
me to work the scientists at
Calico to create a true
partnership between the two
disciplines and build models
that as I mentioned earlier are
so important to combine the best
of both worlds, the best of Big
Data but the best of human
intuition.  Biology is so
complex that I don't think that
even with amounts of data we're
collecting today we'll be able
to reconstruct biology deNovo
from data alone.  You need the
data, but you also new the
intuition of the best
scientists.  By work together at
a place like Calico, we can get
some of those insights as well
as some of enormous amounts of
data currently collected and
I'll come back to that later to
really construct and end up
understanding the biology of
aging and at the same time try
and predict which interventions
Thank you, DAF fee.  I feel we
should pause.  A lot of profound
thinking.
Hang onto your hats.  We jump
back to vision and Faye Faye,
just the other day you were
quoted in tech crunch saying
vision is the killer app of AI.
So what mean by that?  What
does it mean to Democrat
Democratize AI and what does
that have to do with the Cloud?
I was trying to be provocative.
The quote is while many people
are asking for the killer app
of computer vision, I would say
the killer vision is the killer
app of AI.  So let me qualify
that for -- by two reasons.  The
first reason comes from nature.
540 million years ago a
remarkable event happened in
animal evolution.  For some odd
reason, the number of animal
species went from very few
simple species to an explosive
increase of the variety and the
types of animals.  It was
considered the big Ben of
evolution or the cam BREE YA
explosion, and zoologists were
puzzled for many decades why it
happened.  Recently a very
convincing and FROM  prominent
theory conjectured it was the
concept of eyes.  When eyes
first developed in animals,
suddenly the animals -- the
animal life became proactive.
predators and preys and the
whole evolution just changed.
540 million years later, humans
are the most intelligent visual
animals.  In fact, nature
devoted half the her brain for
visual processing because of its
importance.  So that's one
thread of one evidence.  Another
piece of evidence comes from
technology and the world we live
in.  If you look at our
Internet today where data is
awash, YouTube alone seeing
300-plus hours of videos
uploaded every single minute.
It's estimated more than 80% of
the entire cyberspace is in some
kind of pixel form.  Look at
the sensors.  The biggest data
form that sensors capture are in
some kind of images, whether
it's visible spectrum or a
spectrum outside of visible
lights.  From biology labs to
hospitals, from self-driving
cars to surveillance cameras,
everywhere the pixel format,
data and pixel format is the
most invaluable data for
consumers and companies.  At
Cloud I had the chance to talk
to a lot of customers.  I have
been all about the demand of
image recognition and video
processing and analytics.  It's
an exciting time for vision.
Similar to speech recognition
thanks to the progress of deep
neural net.   really taken off
as a field and has made a lot of
progress.  In the past ten
years, between 2010 and -- seven
years to 2017, I would say that
the biggest progress in
computer vision is the basic
perception tasks.  Object
recognition, image tagging,
object detection. already have
-- you see products coming out
of it.   and pedestrian
detection in self-driving cars
and all this.  The next phasing
investing in computer vision
technology, in my opinion, is
really vision plus X.  Vision is
so fundamental in
communications and language, how
do we speak stories?  How do we
tag and index videos so the
connection and interplay between
vision and language is going to
be extremely interesting.  Then
vision in biological sciences,
whether we're -- the through-put
of data coming from biology and
health care and medicine in
vision form is phenomenal.  Be
it radiology or laboratories,
and I think there's a huge
opportunity for vision to play.
last example I want to also
give is robotics.  Vision
speaking as a researcher, there
is a lot of excitement now
happening in the area of vision
and robotics.  We've been doing
robotics as long as AI existed
and robots are still not where
they are.  To a large extent,
it's because of its primitive
perception system, and I think
vision can play a huge role.  So
basically I do think vision is
one of the most important
elements of machine intelligence
and also for the transformation
of enterprise and companie
Thank you.
I need to be careful because
we're running out of time.  So
Fernando, how does vision and
visualization help Machine
Learning and maybe to save time,
you could from that go into
where you see the future of
where you can take the
visualization.  Sure.  To
piggyback on her answer here, we
have this amazingly
sophisticated vision system.  We
might as well use it to
understand what these machines
are doing, right?  So Machine
Learning runs on tons of data,
tons of statistics and
probability.  It turns out the
data visualization can be a
secret weapon in trying to
understand what's happening, and
why do we care?  We should care
because of a bunch of different
reasons.  One is interpretive
ability.  Can you interpret
what's coming out of your
models?  Second is debugability.
understanding what's happening
with your models will allow you
to then debug them.   finally
there's also education.  Visual
ization is already playing an
important role when it comes to
education about Machine
Learning.  I also have a final
education piece there that I'm
very excited about, which is
when we start to understand
better, when we use
visualization to understand
better what the systems are
doing, then can we learn from
them?  Can we become better
professionals, better domain
experts in whatever?  If I'm a
doctor, if I'm an architect,
whatever it is, how can I learn
from these very specific systems
and then be better as a
professional?  Another thing
about visualization that I think
is really powerful and really
important to keep track of is
the fact by using visualization,
we're always keeping the human
in the loop.  Right?  And that
is huge, and as we build
autonomous system, we want to
make sure they're behaving well,
so visualization is helpful
there.  I want to tell you a
quick antidote about a moment,
scientific moment when
visualization showed us
something we didn't know before
about a Machine Learning system.
year Google deployed its
multi-lingual translate system,
right?  It was great.  It was
this really exciting moment of
just putting a ton of different
languages in one system and
having the system somehow figure
out how to translate from every
pair of languages.  The extra
BOENT  bonus it did what was
called zero shot translation
where it was able to translate
from pairs of languages they had
not necessarily seen before.
So one of the fundamental
research questions that the
experts doing those systems had
was how is the system resolving
this space of multi-lingual
data?  Is this system creating
something that looks kind of
like, you know, a model over
here for English and a model
over here for Spanish and
another one for Portuguese?  the
system doing something very
different where it kind of mixes
everything up in the same
spaces, and it's maybe learning
something about the semantics
and the meaning of words and not
necessarily what language it
comes from other what language
I'm translating to.  So what we
did is we built a visualization
to look into this.  The really
excited point was when we
started seeing that we visualize
visualized sentences translated
into different languages.  The
really exciting thing is whether
we saw clusters of sentences in
these different languages show
up together.  So if I have a
sentence that I'm translating
from Portuguese to Spanish to
English and vice versa, all of
those representations showed up
clustered together.  Then
another sentence here.  With all
the clusters of all the
languages, and so in other
words, what did we find out?  We
found out that the system was
not partitioning the space into
different languages.  The system
was coming up with a unique
representation of those multiple
languages.  So in other words,
we saw the first signs of a
universal language of something
that we call intraLing what.
amazing.  It was almost as if we
had run this multi-lingual
system through an MRI, and we're
like, whoa, these are the
results.  The other thing that
the visualization allowed us to
do was to look at neighborhoods
that didn't look very well
resolved where a little language
was kind of hanging out by
itself.  Those were translations
that were not good and not high
quality.  So what that tells us
is that the geometry of these
spaces is meaningful, and if you
have a neighborhood sort of
hanging out in the periphery by
itself, you might want to look
at it and debug your system,
right?  So these kind of
superpowers you can have in
understanding and making things
better, making things work
better.  And for the future, one
of the things I'm really
excited about is sort of goes
hand in hand with something that
Fefe is a true add vote
indicate for is Democratizing
AI.  Visualization and other
techniques, but I truly believe
the more different kinds of
people we bring into the fold of
ML, the better off we're going
to be.  Right now, AI still
feels very engineering centric,
and I'm curious what will happen
when we bring in designers,
UXers, scientists that we're
bringing in?  What are the
different possibilities and what
are the different solutions
that we even thought about that
we can then start exploring.
I feel like I should ask you
how is data visual aization
going to help speech
recognition, but I wanted to ask
you about as data gets more
complex, we had all this labeled
data for the training models,
and we do more personalization.
is the technology going, and
what challenges are you excited
about?  It's very interesting.
Each time we jump into a new
problem in speech recognition,
we really have to focus on it in
a sense, you know, when we
start working on YouTube kits,
for example, which was a YouTube
space for children, we really
had to focus on those young
voices that don't speak the same
way we do and don't have the
same pitch range or same way of
chopping words to take this deep
breath and a burst of speech.
We had to focus on it, and we
found a way to fold back that
learning into our generic model
so that Google Home, for
example, would work with your
children as well as it does with
you.  Google Home itself was
all a new environment where we
had to collect new data.  When
that data is available to you,
you can fold it into the models
and keep training.  The first
time you want to launch a Google
Home device, you don't have it,
right?  So we did a lot of
simulations, taking data, adding
noise of different types, doing
different types of
reverberation on the data.
Indeed, we used massive amounts
of data.  We tribed tens of
thousands of hours of speech and
multiply it with the
simulations.  If you do the
math, it averages to something
like, you know, a handful of
speech that we can fold into a
model.  So just massive amounts.
I think it is very interesting
to think about how that scales
to more problems with different
acoustic characteristics but to
different languages.  If I can
ask you guys how many speak
another language than English?
Right.  see all the hands are
raising, so we really want to
make our technology available to
all of you in your own
language, and if you think of
it, it's a massive problem.  How
do you do that?  Do we build
one recognizer that works for
all of us?  Are we going to do
like we do now, one per
language.  How about dialects,
then, and how are we going to do
it when we have a language
that's a fairly small pocket of
individuals.  So if you ask
linguists they will tell you
that there's 6,000, 7,000
languages in the world.  tell
you that there are about 1,000
of them, actually 1342 they say
that have more than a 100,000
speakers.  that's a lot, right?
If we want really going into
deep internationalization and
serve all the languages that
have big populations on Earth,
it's going to require a lot of
creativity on the Machine
Learning side to manage to share
data among languages known from
other languages and so on.
It's really exciting and there's
a ton of work to do in that
domain.   agree.  It's super
exciting.  Thank you.  going to
go a little over so we have time
to hear about the future from
Faye Faye and Daphne.  Faye
Faye, what excites you about
what's possible going forward?
excites me about what's
possible going forward, let me
just say one dimension.  I
genuinely believe AI is one of
the driving forces of the fourth
industrial revolution.  It's
just the beginning, but it has
the potential to transform so
the way humans live, work,
communicate, and one favorite
line I heard from a philosopher
is there's no independent
machine values.  Machine values
are human values.  So one thing
that really excites me is to
include the diverse
technologyists in the field of
AI to build the future together.
we have that diversity of
representation in the field of
AI technology, we will build the
technology that is for the
entire humanity, not just a
slice of it.  You have a lot of
credibility when you say that.
And Daphne, the intersection of
biology and computing and
everything else you've done.
When I look at the progress that
Machine Learning has made over
the last five to ten years and
as a long-time AI researcher, if
you asked me even five years
ago, will computers be able to
caption images without any kind
of prior knowledge, just in the
same quality a human would,
maybe in 20 years.  With the
work of Faye Faye and others,
we've been able to reach that
milestone way sooner than I
would have expected.  The reason
I move back to biology from
that is because we hi that knee
in the curve in biology.  When
you look at the current
predictions, there was a paper
published in 2015 called Big
Data, astronomical or genomal?
It looks at the number of human
genome sequence, which is a very
limited part of biological data
captured.  You look at the
historical trend, and that
amount doubles every seven
months, which makes it about
twice as fast as Moore's law.
you look at 2025 and you project
that line, the number of human
genomes sequenced by 2025 will
be on a conservative projection
1 hundred
million and on historical
trendses with 2 bill Kwon.
That's just sequence.  doesn't
count R and A and whole body
images and cellular imaging.  So
we're at the cusp of the
beginning to understands the
most complex system that we've
encountered, which is that of a
biological system.  What makes
us alive?  What forces us to
die?  So I think with that
amount of data and the
techniques the Machine Learning
has developed and will continue
to develop, we have an
opportunity to transform this
science in this way.  I'm
excited to bring them to
communities together to make
that possible.
There's clearly so much more
that we could sit and listen to
here.   a phenomenally
interesting and inspiring panel.
very  Thank you, Diane.
Terrific.
Good morning, everyone.
Doan cheer us.  Cheer the next
speakers.  I'm representing the
platform on Android and this is
Andrey.  We have very special
speakers.  We're excited about
this official announcement of
Kotlin.  We both love it.  We
don't want to take more time
from the SPEESHGZ of honor, so
without further adieu, there
they are.
Applause )
HADI HARIRI:  Hello,
everyone.  That's nice.  So you
know I was thinking the other
day the first time that I ever
did a talk in Kotlin, it was l
ike four and a half years ago,
and they gave me a room for 900
people and 7 people showed up.
it's kind of nice to see more of
you show up today.  Thank you.
Applause )
HADI HARIRI:  I've around 30
minutes, actually a little bit
let, 28 minutes to give you a
whirlwind tour of Kotlin.  I'm
not going to cover the entire
language.  I'm going to show you
as much as I possible can and
how you can use it and where it
provides some benefits, okay?
to do it all with live coding,
so if it goes terribly wrong,
there's a Google video -- a
YouTube video of this as well.
You can watch that.   So we
start with something very simple
you've already seen, data
class.  And I'm in a file called
main, right?  So I create a new
type called money, and it has
an amount of type Nth.  Don't
say anything now.  It has a
currency of type string, okay?
And this is both properties, and
they're going to be read-only
properties, so this is something
that you're already familiar
with.  It's essentially a data
class.  Let's go ahead and
compare that to a Java one that
I have done earlier.  So split
vertically.  Let's get the job
money up.  Let's go down this
side.  Java money, so there you
go.  That's the equivalent of
what I just have written, right?
is a data class that providers
two.  They're immutable, so
they're read-only, and this data
mod fire gives me the two
string.  It gives me the clone,
which in Kotlin is called copy.
It's doing the equals and the
hash code.  That's great,
brilliant, but why do I need
that?  Any good IDE generates
that for me.  It's true, it
does.  The problem is that's
code you have to maintain.  time
you add a new property, you
have to go back and change that
code.  The other issues you have
is you don't know, in fact, if
that code is the standard stuff
that you're -- that ID has
generated for you or you tweaked
it a little bit, okay?  It's
not just about saving on typing
on the first line.  Right.  Now
I go ahead and create a function
main.  Let's close this guy
over here.  And this is like the
top entry point of Kotlin, so
you have a public static void
main in a class.  You don't need
that Kotlin.  In Kotlin you can
put everything in the top
level.  kind of like JavaScript
in a good way.  You don't have
to -- and just I want to
reiterate.  Every function and
everything I show you today I
add it in the file as a top
level thing, but that doesn't
mean that you don't have any
more member functions.   any
class, even a data class can
have member functions but for
brevity, it's top level, okay?
I create a new instance of money
and we call it, for example,
tickets and I'll say money, 100,
and it's going to be dollars,
right?  And I'll get into the
explicit type here, but
essentially what I'm doing is
typing, for instance.  So Kotlin
is strong in it, and isasmuch
as it can infer, it will for
you.  say, for example, popcorn.
say tickets, copy, right?
that's what that's going to do,
basically copy the previous one
for me, and all of the
properties.  So if I don't pass
any parameters in, it's going to
just take the same values as it
has before, okay?  I can pass
on a new parameter.  In Spain
popcorn is seven times the price
of the entry of the cinema, so
that's 500 euros, right?  Now I
can do things like, for
instance, if tickets is not
equal to popcorn, then paren
line, they are different, right?
what this is doing is a
property comparison one by one.
not doing a point of
comparison.  For point of
comparisons, we have the triple
equal, right?  Different to
JavaScript, there isn't like a
chart of 600 different positions
you have to remember.  So this,
by the way, firm ligature, so
don't get confused with that.
introduce a new symbol. go ahead
and run this.  I get they are
different, and if I change this
to 100 and I put this as dollars
and I run this, it's going to
say to you that nothing, because
they are the same, okay?  Now,
one of the features we keep
boosting about is the
interaction between Java and
Kotlin.  We have this Java money
one over here, so I'll create
an instance of it.  Java money
equals Java money, and it will
be 100 and dollars.  If I do
Java money, you can see that I
don't have any getters.  What I
do have is a getter, so I can do
get amount, but if I write get
amount completed, the IDs
replace that for property.  We
don't have getters and setters.
just have properties, so that's
consuming Java from Kotlin, and
if I go over to the Java over
here and let's go ahead and
create a public site, so I have
to declare the type.  equals new
money, 100 dollars and okay.
That's the other thing.  The
semi colon in Kotlin are
optional, and the reason they're
optional is so that you can
have endless arguments over
whether you should use them or
not.  We're trying to compete
with JavaScript there.   Now I
use a Kotlin type from Java, so
I get the getters and setters so
it depends how you use it.
Okay?  different Java files and
Kotlin files in a similar
project working similarly
without any issues.  Let's go
ahead and create some functions.
I'm going to create a suction
called send payment that takes
money, and money.  It's going to
print line the money out.  Of
course, we have string, so I can
say sending money.amount and
you don't have to calibrations
if it's just a single property
you paste in.  Now I can call
this and say, send payment
tickets.   Kotlin, we also have
-- one thing here.  I'm not
defining the return type, okay?
default it's unit, which is
kind of like void but it's not.
actually an object which is
essentially a single instance of
an object, and if it is a unit,
you don't have to put it there,
right?  So I'm going to add a
new parameter here and say with
message and this is a string.
default parameters. here notice
there's no compilation error
because I made a parameter.
This saves a lot in terms of
overloading member functions,
right?  I can just have
different parameters and do what
I want, and you can have
multiple default parameters and
you can alternate which one you
want to parse in, you can also
do named parameters.  In fact, I
could say message equals good
luck, and money equals tickets.
This is kind of useful as well
when you are using --  to Legacy
code, for example, and some
function that you can modify and
it has 600 parameters and 500
of them are true and false.  It
gives you an insight into what
parameters I'm parsing in
in every position.  Okay.  I
love it when people crap --
clap.  Laughter )
three tee I'm thinking to
myself, this is going well.
with Kotlin is whether we have
functions that are really,
really easy, like essentially
returning a single value, you
can just do single expression
functions.  So I omit the return
type.  I just return the actual
function that I want to do,
okay?  So, in fact, this is like
the concept of expression comes
in many places in Kotlin.  For
instance, let's create a
function called convert to
dollars.  Convert to dollars,
and this is going to take money.
we're going to do is here
Wednesday, so that's essentially
a case, right?  So when money
currency is dollars, then we do
return, money as is, right?  I
don't need to do anything.  If
it's euros, then what I do is
return, and we're going to do
money amount times -- sorry.  I
have to create a new instance.
Money and then it's going to be
money amount times big decimal
1.10 and then that's going to be
dollars.  Right?  And a legal
argument exception, not the
currency you're interested in.
So this you can actually treat
as an expression.  I can remove
this return over here, remove
this return over here, put it
just here, and then this just
makes the when always return an
expression.  You can remove the
return here, in fact, and remove
the money here and remove that
there and you get a single
expression.  Okay?   function.
One thing you notice here is
this is giving me an error
because this is, you know, I'm
trying to operate a big decimal
with an end, so we're going to
go and refactor this and call it
big decimal.  Okay?  Talking
about big decimal -- oh, here we
go.  Big decimal, 100 and big
decimal.  I love typing big
decimal.  I
love it.  Okay?  we've got this
over here.   if you look at
actually big decimal, to if I
create a new big decimal, we'll
call it BD1 equals big decimal
100, you can see the BD1 gives
me a bunch of functions like
divide and multiply and all of
these things.  What if I do
something like a percent?  I
want to do a percentage of big
decimal.   inherits from that
and create your own version and
have all of these things.
Kotlin one of the things we
added is extension functions,
which means you take any class
or type and extend it.  I can
take a function of big decimal
and put the name of the class I
want to extend and want to do a
percent.  What is the percentage
that I want to do, for example,
and an integer.  Let's see.
an extension function, it's
going fob an instance of that
class, of that object, right?
So I can use that and reference
that with this, and I say this
multiplied by the percentage,
and then this awrapped in a big
decimal again, percentage, and
then that divide and then
another big decimal 100.  What's
wrong with this?  should be
percentage.  So percentage.
Okay?  So now what happens is
that on BD1 I have percentage.
Okay?  I can do percent 7, and
that would give me 7%.  That
extension function gets included
anywhere where it's defined in
the package, right?  Here in
case I have it there, and that
will be included there.  You can
create extension functions.
The standard library consists of
a whole bunch of extension
functions.  We'll take it one
step further. extends RG, a
integer.  I say fund in percent
of and here we do the reverse.
So I want like 10% of something,
right?  I'll say, money, for
instance, I want 10% of money.
going to return the -- see.  It
will return money, right?  Then
it will be amounts multiplied,
and then here it references the
actual instance, so it will be
this and again this has to be
wrapped in
big decimal.  And then divide by
100, okay?  I think I got that
in the right order.  If the
implementation is wrong, it
doesn't matter.  Who cares.
now what I can do is go like
this.  7% of big decimal 100.
Okay?  No, sorry.  Money.  I can
do money.  No,
don't clap yet.  Money -- let's
just take the money I have.  7%
of popcorn, okay?  Nice?
Applause )    HADI HARIRI:
Let's do something nicer.  I
want to do something like this.
I want to do 7% of popcorn.
That would be nice.  You can do
that.  You see that wiggly
there, alt, enter, add and fix.
There you go.  Any extension
function that has a single pa
parameter can be called in an
fix notation and I add it over
there.  This is some of the
things that allow you now with
Kotlin to create the whole DSL
approach to things.  Right.  one
thing that I hated doing here
is all of this big decimal. a
pain, all right?  In Kotlin when
you wanted to create a value of
type long, you can say long
100L, and that will be a type
long.  I know it would be
awesome if I can do BD2 equals
100BD, but you can't.  We don't
have that built in.  What we do
in Kotlin is called extension
properties, so they're exactly
like extension functions except
them extends with properties.  I
could do something like .BD,
right?  And now -- yeah.  So now
-- see it says, do you want to
create an extension property on
type integer?  Yes.  So this is
going to return a big decimal.
Right?  And then here I'm going
to do return, big decimal, and
this, which is the instance,
right?  I can, in fact, convert
this to an expression to make it
easier, right?  There you go.
Now I have 100.BD.  When I pass
that in, it looks much nicer
than big did hes ma'am.  I can
do 100.BD,
okay?  One other thing around
functions you can do is there
are certainly operators that you
can extends.  You can extend
the plus operator, and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to type
this out.  I have a nice little
thingy that did that for me.
how fast I am at typing?  So
what I've done is now override
the plus operator for money.  So
now I can say how costs equals
tickets plus popcorn, right?
allows me to add two monetary
amounts, okay?  You can do that
with plus, mine, multiply, a
bunch of built-in conventions
to follow for certain operators
that allow you to do that.
Okay.  So we've been creating a
whole bunch of types here, and
let any go ahead and delete all
this stuff so we can focus.
We've been creating a BUFRNL of
types here.  Notice in the types
I created I never actually
specified the type.  can.  So I
can do, for instance, train
costs, for example, the train is
of type money, and then
initialize it to some new value,
right?  100.BD and then
dollars.  Now, if I go ahead and
do train equals now, it's going
to give me an error, and it
will give me two errors.  is
because that's a mutable
variable, so I can fix that.  I
made this mutable.  You see the
ID underlines it, so it wants to
point out that this is really
something you have to shy away
from.  We don't it enforce
immutability but derecommend it.
the lites and things are
immutable by default.  I can't
assign now in Kotlin, because it
tries to get rid of the pointer
exception by saying types
aren't by default, right?  There
are times to have a type that
is knowledgeable for whatever
reason, you're bored, and you
can add a question mark and then
that will give you the ability
to assign null to that type,
right?  Normally whether you
work with Kotlin, you don't want
to do this.  You don't want to
have null types.  Since we
interact with Java, it can be
null.  If I create a function
here that is, for
instance, Java money and that
takes Java money and does
whatever with it, right?  Let's
say I do print line,
money.amount is valid, so this
can be now -- if it's called by
an instance, a function that for
example is returning this time,
it could be null.  You can
indicate that by adding the
question mark.   do that, you
can see that the IDE gives you
an error. safe operators or
double exclamation mark is valid
here.  an all-reference
exception.  There's two ways to
solve T. First of all, you can
say for example money not now
and then do if not now then go
ahead and operate with it.  Put
this one upstairs in there,
okay?  That's one way.  Or the
shorter way is just to use the
safe operator or Elvis operator,
which is over here.  So now we
just say if money is not null,
then do something.  Now, if you
want to have fun, you can also
do that.  That says I know it's
null, but I want to shoot myself
in the foot, okay?  You got to
be careful with that, because a
lot of times when people start
with Kotlin, they get little
squiggles over here.  They don't
know if it's null because I
want it to not be null, so I'm
not going to handle the case now
so I'll do that.  They run the
app, and they're like, wait a
minute, UGSD Kotlin got rid of
exceptions.  Yes.  Okay.  What
else?  Right.  So let's switch
to other stuff like higher order
functions.  You're all familiar
with a higher order function,
which is basically a function
that takes a function and
returns a function.  We have
those in Kotlin.  We can say
find e-mails, and list of users
and then I create a new
function.  I'm passing a
function here, right?  A
function that takes a string and
returns a bullion, okay?  This
is probably going to return a
list of users.  This is
filtering a list of users,
right?  I'll do this later.  To
do later, okay?  This to do, by
the way, is built in.  You can
use it instead of nonimplemented
error, and it does an
additional thing we won't get
into.  is actually very nice in
Kotlin.  We wouldn't cover that
now.   nothing to
worry about.  I just made that
up.  Okay.  Thank you.  So now
how do I use this?  find the
e-mails, right?  say, I actually
have a user.  Let's create some
users here.  Users from JSON,
so this is actually -- this is
actually a function that I have
ready, which is using JSON to
read some music from a file, and
this is a typical data class
you've seen.  also got a class
of -- with aproperty role, okay?
So now I can do users, and
then I'll pass
in that function.  I can pass
in the name function by using
the quote-unquote research, or I
can pass in the Lambda.  In
Kotlin, lamb BA follows this
syntax.  parse in the PRAR meter
name, and they say the
parameter name ends with.com.
So I'm going a list of users
that end with .com.  Now, when
you have a single parameter in
Kotlin, you can actually admit
having to explicitly mention it
and replace it with it, okay?
So similar to that, you can just
use it.  The other thing in
Kotlin, when the last parameter
to a function is another
function, you can actually not
include it in the brackets.  So
it feels a little bit like it's
outside.  This is, again, one of
the characters that allowed new
DSLs and do it like multi-line.
you look at fine e-mails, it
can feel like it's part of the
language, but it isn't.  It's
actually a function.  When we
implemented a sync  --  with
co-rootings, if you're familiar
with C sharp, it does the same
thing with keywords in the
language.  In Kotlin they're
just functions.  That gives you
the flexibility of decides how
to do different things.  You
don't have to do all of these
things, because they're all
built in.  For example, if I say
.com users, I say users filter,
and you can see as I complete
this it actually opts for the
version of including out of the
parameter.  So I can say the
e-mail ends with dot com and I
can sort by
it.ID and map that to a pair of
it.e-mail and it.user name.
Okay?  So all of these functions
are actually built into the
small standard library.  You
won't have problems on Android
and it's very small.  They're
extension functions on top of
collections. collections, right?
So you have all of those
functional things that, you
know, are very in fashion these
days.  And so
gives me a paren.  Instead of
doing paren it 2 so map e-mail
to user name.  Guess what it is?
just an end fix function that
creates a pair, okay?  Now,
sometimes I don't want to go
through the whole map.  I just
want to, for example, say get
back a single element.  What you
can also
do is destructure data classes
in Kotlin.  So I could do
something like ID, user name,
and e-mail, okay?  And then I
can just like, you know, use the
ID.  This is great, but then
the ID complains and says this
variable is never used.  In that
case you can replace that with
an underscore, right?  So there
you go.  You can destruct the
value you want.  Replace it on
the score, and you're good to
go.  Right.  What else can I
show you?  I have other code
here.  If you're familiar with
the concept of a gentleman Bray
YIK data types, it's a type one
time of another.  For instance,
a bullion.  In Kotlin we do that
with classes, but let me do an
open here.  Notice the first
thing here is that user result
is giving me an error.  By
defaulting Kotlin, you can't in
herit from classes.  All classes
are essentially final.
inherit from classes, use the
open mod fire, right?  Now, I
used the seal, and this is
saying this is the hierarchy
user result has.  not any other
class anywhere that is go to
inhair from user results.
Everything that inherits has to
be in the same fire, or you can
make these subclasses so I can
move this up there and this
would be a subclass.  Then I
have to prefix it with user
results, right?   Now, I've just
created it as a class outside,
so why would I want to do this?
Because it looks good.  No.
This is actually good because
when you do some things, you
invoke a function and you're
like okay, if it's successful
FSHGS I want to return a value.
If it's not, I pass in a
message.  You get this THIEP
that contains the values that
you want to return whether it's
successful.  It contains the
types you return when there's a
message and you have to figure
out the semantics of which
properties applied to an error
situation and non-error
situation, or just throw in an
exception.  In this case you can
use a function that basically
returns two types.  Based on the
result, two do different
things. for instance, when --
create an instance of the value
result equals user results.
Sorry.  Retrieve users.  Okay.
So now I can do when
result is success, then we're
going to do, for instance -- we
get the result, and then we do
users for each.  each
, print line, the name, okay?
User name.  And then we do a
failure result, print line,
result, dot message, okay?  So
now based on the result, based
on the type that is returned to
me, I can do different things.
notice one thing over here that
this is going green.  I don't
know if you see it on the big
screen, but this went green. a
smart cast, and that's another
thing in Kotlin.  You saw that
when I was doing the now check
that said this is not nulled
because it's smart casting.  You
don't have to be over here
again and say, you know, I know
that this is of type success.
Let me go ahead and cast this to
type success to access the
property.  The compiler will do
that for you.  what the
smartcasting is. but not least
before I hand it off to Andrey,
a lot of things you've seen with
the filter map, all of those
things, those are essentially
eager evaluation, right?  We
also have the availability to do
lazy evaluations.  So I can
generate sequence and then have
something, for instance, 1.  And
then here we'll do it times 10.
then we'll do values, right? I
say values take
10, and then for each print line
it.   this is essentially
creating a sequence, a generator
that is infinite, it won't stop
and start at 1 and multiply by
10.  I'm saying that I want to
take 10 elements and then print
them out.  What it will do is
basically consume that until it
hits of ten.  It printed out --
It prints out a beautiful
Christmas tree.  one-sided.
Okay?   whatever.  And it stops
there, and anything that you
have like, for example, the
users that we had, you know,
users from JSON, users.JSON, you
can say as sequence and
converted into lazy evaluation
as well.  Okay?  That's all we
have the time to show you today.
there's way more to the
language.  Go online and learn
everything about it, and thank
you very much.  I'll hand it off
to Andrey.  Applause )
ANDREY BRESLAV:  Thank you,
Hadi.  Hello, everybody.  As you
see, Kotlin already has many
things in store, but I'm the
nasty person who adds new
features before you learn the
existing ones.  So I tell you
stories now, but I need to find
a clicker.  Do you have a
clicker?  No.  Okay.  Okay.  So
I'll be telling stories without
a clicker.  So my job here is to
tell you about what we're going
to have in the future versions
of Kotlin.  Thank you very much.
And first big thing we're
working on now is platforms,
supporting different platforms.
compiles to the code same as
the Java language.  We can run a
server on the desktop and
Android.   the same byte code
everywhere.  This is why we can
run old verges of Android as
well as new ones.  The story
doesn't end there.  We add new
platforms and recently we added
-- the guy doesn't like
platforms.  Recently we added
JavaScript, which means Kotlin
can now compile to JavaScript
code and run in the browser or
on no GS.  So now we support
three major very popular Virtual
Machines, JVM, Android, Dole
DRIK and JavaScript.  There are
many use cases where a Virtual
Machine is not practical or
simply unavailable.  For
example, for iOS, Virtual
Machines are severely
restricted.  For a small
embedded system, VM doesn't fit
in or a Linux command line tool,
the VN will be a starting tool
for too long.  It's a no-go
there.  That's why we work on
cull Lynn native.  It's a t
echnology preview.  There we use
LVM to compile Kotlin down to
native code that runs on
different platforms.  Currently
we expect iOS, Linux and Mac and
Windows is in the works.  This
is with the vision with Kotlin
when it can run inside every
component on any platform you
like.  Think full stack web
applications with the server and
the client both written in
Kotlin, or use code between
multiple platforms, Android and
iOS, for example, or mix of the
two previous use cases and get a
real multi-platform scenario.
our vision for Kotlin is having
different modules in the same
project compiled to different
platforms.  Of course, you want
to share code there, right?  If
you support so many different
things, you want to run the same
code in different places.
We're working on making that
possible.
There is a very important
thing.  Recently many try to
unify platforms and this is the
least common denominator when
you take things available on all
platforms.  You're stuck with a
minimal interface, and that's
something we don't want to have
there.  We want to be able to
use all the platform like the
newest version of Android or
something else as much as you
like.  If you want to share
code, only then you have to
resort to some common APIs.  So
the idea there is you have a
common module with lots of
business logic and stuff.  It
works side by side with a
platform-specific model written
in Kotlin.  Those two can talk
to each other.  When you need to
leverage the platform API and
when you need use the common
code.  So take away here, our
future is multi-platform.   --
Applause )    ANDREY BRESLAV:
Next big thing is coroutines.
The rational is  needs to write
a SIRNG NUS code, right?  The
world is too big for sequential
execution.  It's a reality, but
it's hard, right?  Who has
written a synchronous code?  Not
so many hands.  Those that
don't actually will be doing
this very soon.  The problem is
it's hard to write the code or
it was hard before languages
supported you in doing that,
because language helps a lot.
What we have with coroutines in
cot up Lynn, you write the
asynchronous code as synchronous
code.  Things like that, right?
It's the same things you're
using with coroutines for aSING
chronous code so the language
keeps tracks of everything and
you don't have to express any
intricate control flow in the
code.  No callbacks and fancy,
functional structures.  It's
just plain old
sequential-looking code.  Isn't
it cool?  Thank you.  Yes.  The
idea with coroutines is that
you basically have the same
abstraction for asynchronous and
sing NUS.  It's a night
metaphor to think of them as
three threads.  Here's the code
example I show you.  Basically
very many things traditional
down with threads can be down
with coroutines, but they're
extremely cheap.  I have a code
that creates 1 hundred,000 KWARN
tees in parallel.  Each one
waits for one and returns one.
completes in one second --
almost one second, because all
the
coroutines wait in parallel, of
course.  If you try to do this
with threads, it doesn't work.
100,000 threads don't fit into
memory.  That's with.  With
coroutines it's a win-win
situation.  You get lots of
performance, so it's very
efficient and the code is
simple.  Take away here.  Check
out
coroutinesbecause our future
will likely be more asynchronous
than the present.  to learn
more about Kotlin, check out our
website, and we have a section
for Android and also we have a
question and answer session
right after this talk.  So come
over to the developer sandbox
section C, myself and Hadi will
be answering questions there.
very much for your attention.
Applause )
.
Hello, everyone.  How is it
going?   So this session is
going to be a little different
right?
We should introduce ourselves.
I'm Paul and he's Jake.  We're
doing web stuff for a while so
we wrote a quiz that looks at
the wonderful corners of the
web.  We'll difficult into the
answers to help you in your
projects for apps.  Of course,
the quiz inside is a PWA.  Get
your laptops and smartphones
ready, because we're going to
play the BIG WEB QUIZ.  Oh, yes.
did take six hours.  Worth
every minute.  If you want to
play along, go to bigwebquiz.com
and log in with your Google
account.   where we panic about
the server falling down.  We
tested that.  With a little
luck, it should be okay.  Your
laptop screwed up on the stage
last year.  It's the new laptop.
The first time I presented
from it.  It's going to be fine.
Is everyone logged in?  Is
that sort of thing working?
up.  We're winning.  Last time
we did it people were shaking
their heads and we were like,
what do we do now?  Blind panic.
LEWIS:  We're going to show the
top players at the end of the
game and points throughout and
only with your permission.  If
you want appear on the
leaderboard click on the avatar
and click appear on leaderboard.
If you phoned in six to come
here instead, don't opt in
because your massive face might
give away things a little bit.
Of course, no quiz is complete
without a grand prize.
Unfortunately, unfortunately the
organizers of Google I/O said
we can't have our own give-away
but we came up with a
compromise.  What if our prize
was of such low quality that
winning it would kind of feel
like losing?   play the BIG WEB
QUIZ OP into the leaderboard and
use your web knowledge to make
it into the top three, you're
the proud owner of the official
BIG WEB
QUIZ mouse pad.
Oh, yeah.   get the mouse pad.
Irish is sold separately.
watching this on the live
stream, hello.  Feel free to
play along as well.  You can't
win the mouse pad,
unfortunately.  There's a delay,
right?  About 30 seconds behind
reality.  You need to watch for
the questions appearing on your
device as the question may end
before the video makes its way
to you.  If you're watching this
on the live stream now, we
probably started the first
question already because we do
that in 30 seconds and you're
living in the future right now.
We don't want to confuse you.
Maybe sure everything is
working.  Let's see if it works.
Devices at the ready. comes
the
does PWA stand for?  Is it
progressive web app, produced
with angular, partially wheeled
automobile or perfectly
waterproofed anorak.  The
question should be appearing on
your phones now.  Pick the
answer you think is correct and
hit submit.  Very important that
you hit submit.   you do that,
let's see how the results are
looking.  So what we see here is
the percentage of you picking
each answer.  However, the order
is randomized compared to your
devices, it may not be in the
same order.   see you're all
converging on one particular
answer.  Wonder which one that
might be?  Should we Clowe the
question? BALD:  We close the
question in three,  it is.  Oh,
okay.  So produced with angular.
That's interesting.
Obviously, someone hasn't
really thought about it in the
session yet.  The correct answer
is, of course, progressive web
app.  We didn't award points for
that question, since it's just
practice.  One thing we want to
stress is you have to hit that
submit button once you pick the
answer. else we don't find about
it.  During our rehearsal,
colleagues didn't realize that.
fix the problem, we thought
we'd gather tape over it with
this slide and press the button.
Just read the instructions.
Everybody knows what they're
doing, so let's get serious now,
I think.  From now on each
question will award a maximum of
four points.  That's a nice
number.  Power of two.  We kick
it on with a deep dive into
loading stuff.  If you want to
build a app, you need to limit
the time from the user clicking
link and having your app on the
screen using it.  This is the
difference between a fast app
and slow app, of course.
Ideally a progressive web app
should load bit by bit.  Some
loading techniques get in the
way of pausing and paints and
that can result in the
browser downloading stuff and
once everything is downloaded,
tah-dah, there's a big reveal.
BAZ for the user staring at a
wide screen wondering if it's
downloaded.  This improves the
perception of performance
because things appear much
sooner.  This is good as well,
because they can create the
elements which is much faster
than all the downloads in one
stop and all of the parsing in a
separate step.  That brings us
to the next question.  So
devices at the ready.  Here it
comes.  Which of the following
script elements blocks the
parser while the script
downloads.
The normal script time there
and a script with defer and a
script with A
sync and async that's false.
You get points for those true
and not for those false.  You
get four points fully right and
two points for half right.  It
might be somewhere in the
middle.  You can submit as many
times if you want.  If you
change your mind at the last
second, do that and hit the s
ubmit button.  Let's look at the
voting.  How are things going?
Already we've got a spread of
answers.  We have two that
you're confident on and two less
confident on.  You've had
enough time to guess, so if you
haven't guessed already, guess
but we're going to lock the
question.  Three, two, one, lock
it.   think a normal script
element and async will do the
same.  The correct answer?  It's
just that one.  the normal
script.  There's happy people
and less happy people.  Although
it was a multi-select only one
was correct.  Scripts are awful
by defaults.  They block parsing
download and execute.  Deferred
to async scripts don't block
the parser while they download.
The difference between the two
when they execute.  They always
execute in the order they
discover this.  Async scripts
execute as soon as they
download, and that means they
can learn in DAFRNT
-- a different order.  It was
in the list.  It ignores the
value completely.  So you say
that AC equals false is true
which I adore.  That's true.
That's true of most HTML stuff.
either there or not.   is where
you can set things to be false.
Let's talk about when to use
the right one, which one is
best.  Having the script execute
in any order is probably risky,
because if you have five async
scripts, you have 120 different
permanent YAGSs of execution
order.  If one causes failure,
you don't know where you're at.
That's a tricky bug to
reproduce and resolve.  They run
a PROO  predictable time in
order. you have a long article
and your script is to enhance
the button, it's a big waste of
time to download to enhance the
little button at the top there.
JavaScript blocks the parser.
So async could cause in the
middle of the page load.
answer is really depends.  Test
it and do whatever gives the
best user experience.  Tools not
rules is a guiding principle
here.  At the end of the
question, we will show a set of
links to resources and
documentation for the things
that we've been talking about in
case you don't believe us or
want to learn more about a
particular area.  We've
discussing these scripts here,
but they're old and have been
around for years.  There is a
new way to load JavaScript.
Scripts can be loaded as modules
and this makes it a bit
different.  Module scripts are
internal resources or inline
like normal scripts.  exciting
thing is use import statements
to load scripts.  supported in
safari in the stable version
right now, but it's behind the
flag in Chrome, Firefox and
Edge.  I think it's the best way
to load script.  On that note,
here comes a really cruel
question.  Devices at the ready.
Here we According to the
specification, which of the
folks scripts executes first?
been practicing it backstage in
his hotel room.  awkward.  So we
have type people module and
defer with something in line.
Which one executes first.  What
are you saying so far?  There's
a debate around two answers.
It's fairly -- If you haven't
guessed already, get a guess in.
close the question in three,
two, one.  It's closed.   what
we are saying here, some think
script 1 will execute first,
which makes sense in terms of
numbers.  It's the first number.
That's how we write the
questions.   think script two
which isn't the first number.
The answer, though, it is script
3.  Oh, yes.  Someone is very
happy at the front there
okay.  Here's why that is.  The
way scripts block execution by
default while they download,
that was a bad design mistake.
module scripts have a different
default and are deferred.  The
same goes for inline module
scripts, and this is pretty new.
Regular inline scripts cannot
be deferred, so in this case the
attribute is totally ignored
making it a normal script that
executes immediately first.  You
can use async as well and it
can excould you tell us as soon
as all the imports download.
This is important, but not
fetching it at all is better.
We'll take a dive into caching
stuff, and there are two we're
interested in here.  When the
page fetches something, it looks
for a match in the HTBC cash.
It makes a connection and says,
it's this old and shaped.  The
server can say no, no, don't use
that.  a newer version, or it
sends back a tiny messages
saying you're good to use what
you've got.  If that happens,
they send it back to the page.
however, the browser makes a
fetch and finds a result in the
HTBC cash but this time it
doesn't need to vault date so it
uses it and doesn't ask the
server at all.  That's faster
for small assets makes the
request is the majority of the
work.   to use it is the cash
control response header which
takes a variety of values.
variety. what they are and what
they do?   didn't.  at the
ready.  Here is the next
question.  This one.  does the
header as a response header say
to do?  put this in the cache?
it mean cache it, but you can
only use it after server
validation or cache it and use
it without server validation for
31,536 seconds, which is a
year. Let's look at the votes.
I love it.   on two of them.
That's exciting.  Some happy and
some sad and some
confused.  in.  Lock it in.
you say cache it but
you can use it after a
validation or use it without
validation some of you are
saying.  The answer is, of
course, it is you can use it
without server validate.  Some
think it must validate.  That
would be weird.  It means that
the browser once revalidate once
it expires.  If it's under that
age, it can use it without
checking in with the server.
what about this  --  does cache
instead of using no revalidate.
question, same answer.  Look
at the voting.  It's easy,
right?  We have a 50/50
situation between two of them.
One is winning.  good.  A lot
concentrating faces in the
audience, which makes me very
happy on the inside.  We're
closing the question in three,
two, one. closed.  Right.  Okay.
So we say no cache would mean
do not put this in the cache.
The answer is cache it, but you
can only use it after server
validation.   what some of you
think no cache is no cache.
That's shorthand, so the
additional Max age is
acknowledged.  No cache means
the browser may use the cache
but has to check with the server
first.  We don't know why
they're named like this.  They
had a lot of features and good
names for them, and then they
put them in a bag and picked
them out at random.  This
happens to involve naming things
with cache validation.
destined to fail.  Like we said,
it's best to avoid a request if
possible, so for some resources
treat it as a useable.  Let
that cache for as long as you
can, which is a year.  If you
wanted to update this resource,
you need to change the URL.
There are a lot of build system
tools that help with, one of
which is web pack.  They all
have their own.   plenty of
them.  Not all is immutable.
page that the user visits
directly.  In this case it's
best to use no cache.  That
means that the browser will
check in with the server first.
you have private data, tell the
browser not to start at all,
which is working quite a while
well.  That came out at the
right time.  If you've given an
untrustworthy person the cache,
you have bigger problems.
People say it's just paranoia.
a caching problem we see around
the web and leads to weird
behaviors, because sometimes one
of the benefits of avoiding it
the go going to the network, but
haven't set up the build
system. go with regular URLs
like script JS and XPT  expect
it to change over time and they
take a guess.  How does a couple
of hours sound?  Two hours
soundses like a good compromise.
really isn't.  We see it on
static services as well.  Don't
do this.  Here's why.  Let's say
you serve some JavaScript and
tell it to cache for two hours.
download the lot, right, and
they have the resources on the
cache and on the page.  So far
so good.  It's all working.  say
an hour later you update your H
TML in JavaScript so there's
version 2, now.  You don't
change the URLs.  You browse
around the web and the browser
decides I've had enough of those
two and it removes it.  Maybe
you think why would the browser
do that?  The browser can remove
whenever it wants to. it wants
space back.  That's the Max age
from the point downloaded you
can get them out of sync and
they expire at different points.
They get the CSS from the cash
within the two hours, but the
other assets come from the
network.  There you have version
2 of your HTML and JavaScript,
but you're still on version 1 of
the CSS.   result could be fine
and get away with, maybe, or
end it with broken and styled
stuff.  It's a big gamble and
hard to figure out why if it
breaks.  Either use no cache or
immutable resources with a year
of caching.  Another part of
page load is timing.  resources
start downloading pretty late.
The most common is web fonts I
would say.  They're defined in
your CSS including how to
download them and where to use
them.  Once they downloaded CSS
is performs a recount on the
page.  At this point it
discovers a web fonts  font for
one or more paragraphs on the
page.  The browser lays out the
page and paints it, but this
misses the text that needs the
web font.   seen this.  We saw
this really, really.  I just
wanted to read it.  It's pretty
frustrating, right?  Once the
font has downloaded, the browser
performs again and paints the
page this time with the text
using the web font.   isn't
optimal.  It starts to download
so late and the result is the
user is left without content.
the content on the device and
they refuse to download it and
refuse to paint it.   improve
things a lot.  With this in the
head of the document you need
the resource to load the page.
download happens in parallel
with the CSS.  You see the time
between the download is
massively reduced, and that
means the user gets content
quicker, which is great.   you
use the preload, it's stored in
a special preload cache until
the browser needs it.  We have
the preload cache and there's
another.  In ATV2 the browser
can ask the server for something
and here it is.  Also here's
some other stuff you -- this is
called ACTB2 push.  It sends out
an additional response and
information the browser needs
for when to use the responses.
is, this cache, it's a
completely different cache from
the other two, which brings us
to our next question.  Devices
at the ready.  Which cache does
the browser check first?  Is it
the push cache, the preload
cache or HTTP cache.  I didn't
know this until talking to the
networks team.  This is what we
see here.   answer more than
others.  The confidence is
waning, Jake.  Hit that submit
button.  We're closing the
question.  Three, two, one.
closed.  Oh, the HTTP cache is
winning that one.   answer among
Googlers when we did rehearsal.
Just like the Googlers, wrong.
The correct answer is the
preload cache.   As you can see,
some of these questions are
deliberately obscure, so really
do not feel bad if you get them
wrong.  A Googler was in a
rehearsal.   all fired, by the
way.  They don't work here
anymore.  If you end up with a
top score, it means you didn't
learn a lot from this talk.  You
wasted your time.  Unless you
win the mouse pad.  That's
desirable prize.  I'm glad they
didn't applaud that. cache is in
play here, and it's pretty
complicated but knowing the
stuff helps to prevent loads of
weird bugs.  browser fetches it
as normal to the server and it
ends up in the memory cache
alongside the page.  The things
to note is your preloaded stuff
comes from the HTTP cache, but
also since it sits with the
page, other pages don't use it.
They may have their own preload
caches, but one page doesn't
use another page.   pointsless
for another page and maybe the
next page.  page has its own
preload cache.  The cash sits
with the connection, and that
makes it pretty difficult to
preload because two pages share
it so they can share the same
push cache.  Things for one page
may be consumed by another.
That's pretty complicated.  You
can push something the user has
in their cache.  No browser does
that yet.  The answer to the
actual question, it checks the
preload cache first and the HTTP
cache and then the push  That's
it.  a good thing to keep in
mind.  It's a bit out there, but
at the same time if you find
you've got weird behaviors, it's
good to know where to start
I think HTTP is powerful and
low level and many cases preload
is a simpler, more reliable St.
Louis and  -- and DevTools are
available.   we look at the
leaderboard?  Let's see how
you're doing.  Oh.  One person
is in the lead at the moment.  A
ndreiis first at 20 points.
We're only halfway through.  CSS
and rendering, that might be
your thing and might be your
time to shine.   talk a little
about rendering.  are important
to communicate to the user and
they look really cool.  We've
had a lot of fun with animation
so far.  Badly performing
animation can be really jarring,
often worse than any animation
at all. Modern browsers have
compositing, and this means they
take an particular element and
temporarily isolates it into its
own layer.  If the conditions
are correct, the browser does
this automatically for
animation.  It minimizing it as
the browser doesn't keep
repainting the thing behind the
element doing the animation.  At
the end of the animation, it
can merge down and FLAPTen that
content back with the other
content on the page.  As Paul
said, it needs to be correct to
happen.  We're animating a
circle in the SVG.  Which will
be deposited in Chrome 57.  Is
it center X, center X transform
and transform and opacity.
like your quiz How do you vote
now?  Strong feelings, free of
them and less confident with one
of them.  Get a guess in if you
haven't already.  We're going
to close the question in three,
two, one.  Don't forget to hit
submit.  So we have a transform
there, so yeah, that's the
transform.  The correct answer
is none
of them.  That's cruel, isn't
it?  I know.  For implementation
in Chrome today, it's fair to
say we'd love to see it change,
compositing never happens for
elements inside of an SVG
element.  This means your
animations are going to paint as
a flat, single layer every
frame.
Edge and Firefox support but
Chrome does not.  Is it
something we're looking at?
We'll post a link to the Chrome
book.  That's SVG. talk about
your standard issue dom.  Which
of the following automations can
be deposited in Chrome 57.  Is
it margin left, within
transform, transform or opacity.
Can I XHENDZ commend you on
your quiz voice?  Let's look at
the voting.  Similar kind of
feel to last time, I'd say.
People are holding onto their
previous answers.  Will it pay
off for them?  It's a bold play.
Three, two, one.  We close.
The margin left is less
confident on.  The correct
answer is, of course,
three.  That was a good show.
that transitions on opacity
will transform.  If you declare
the animation up front using
CSS, the browser can probably
move the whole thing away from
the main thread.  It can
continue junk-free even if it's
busy.  If it's deposited it may
have a frame by frame dependency
on the main spread.
Absolutely.  correct answer of
with two seconds, transform two
seconds is one of these.  Sure,
the element was going to get so
late if you animate transform.
true.  If you animate width,
even if something has its own
layer, you will trigger the
layout and paint per frame.
These are bound pieces of word.
It's true they're faster in
layers of paint.  You try to do
layout and paint per frame is
not normally fast on a
smartphone.  In fact, layout is
scoped to the DON dom, that's
what you have.  That's not what
you want from animation.   have
to stick to transforms and
opacity and animate the
properties.  Just because an
element has its own layer
doesn't mean it's safe to start
animating properties like left
or margin or something like
that.  Let's switch to
event-based animation and get
JavaScript in there as well.  Is
this your favorite?   really
enjoy this one.  You have an
element with no transform and
the following code.  According
to the specification, what
happens next?  What's going on?
Does it transform?  We have a
position on transform, and we
set it to 100 pixels and it
slides to the left and right or
snap to 100 pixels.  Let's see
how people are voting.  There's
one answer that people -- what's
interesting is two answers are
unpopular, and I thought would
have been significantly less
popular than any of them.  Turns
out not.  Get a guess in if you
haven't already.  Hit submit.
closing the question in 3, 2, 1.
You're locked in.
Interesting.  people think it
does the Maceren
a.  You have given up on the
quiz.  One of the highest scores
in HEE herselfal was the design
advocate, and he's just making
random guesses.   anymore.  The
correct answer, of course, when
it appears on the screen, it
slides to the right.  Now, Paul,
I did maps at school, and I was
led to believe that 200 is a
bigger number than 100.
Therefore moving from 100 to 200
would be to the left.  While I
agree with you, you did say
maths, and I think it will be
math.  I don't know.  It's
Matttics so the abelieve YAGS is
maths is my strong opinion.
America, I could live with it,
but then you took the S you
saved and you put it on the end
of Lego.  Legos, the toy is
Lego.  Legos is an island off
the coast of Spain
probably.  Let's move on.  does
it slide to the right?
Browsers try to reduce the
workload, and they run event
call backs.  At the end the
renders pass begins and they
take stock of any style changes.
By that point that translate
into 200 pixels has been written
over by 100 pixels. the browser
is concerned, the animation
should be from no transform at
all to 100 pixels.  When the
frame is shipped, it will slide
to the right.  Thousand the dom
layer sees it, we do it before
it takes note of it, right?
Exactly.  If we slide from the
right to left, it takes hold
before we overwrite it to 100
pixels.  that in mind, here's
the next question.  You have an
element with no transform.  It's
the same question, really, and
the difference is we have that
final transform wrapped inside a
request animation frame.  Does
it slide to the right?  Does is
it slide to the left?  Does is
it snap to 100 pixels and does
it feel only sadness?  Basically
a web developer.  Let's see how
you are voting.  We're less
sure this time dividing the room
except for one particular
answer.  Guess a guess in if you
haven't already.  We're closing
the question in three, two,
one.
locked in.  So what do we see
here.  Pretty much equal
guessing.  That tends to happen
with this quiz at this point.
just spread out evenly among the
non-ridiculous answers.  The
correct answer, though, is once
again it slides to the right.
Watch, tah-dah!   Tell me why.
the transforms are 200 pixels
and thought we waited a frame
and set it to 100 pixels.
Surely it took hold and we
animated.  But, no, the spec
says once again things should be
different to them.   the same
as before.  The event callback
is part of a task, and we get to
the rendering bits of the event
loop and that is animation
callbacks and they think about
styles and such doing the actual
painting because they happen
before the calculation, the net
result is the same.  We overrate
the value before the style
system sees it. talk about what
we can do then if we wanted to
solve this. apply is to not call
request animation frame but
call it twice.  Take that in and
injoy that.  If you request an
animation callback while it's
running, they will run in the
next event loop, which would
mean you have something at 200
pixels before transferring to
100 pixels.  The downside is you
have ridiculous-looking code
and in extra frame.  In Safari
you wait two frames because they
don't follow the specs.  They
follow the expectations.   we
thought Chrome was buggy.  CR
bug and everything.  Perhaps you
don't want to do so this kind
of ridiculous double wrapping
and you want to force that style
recalculation to happen
synchronously.  You see it
transform before it changes to
100 pixels.  SHA we have a
question on that?  Here it says
answering this here to force a
synchronous update in Chrome 57.
width and get computed style in
a text.  Select all that apply.
Multi-select one.  Let's see
how people are voting.  We're
confident on one of them, unsure
about two of them.  One of them
is out of room.  It's kind of
REEZing.  We close the question
in a couple of seconds so take a
guess if you haven't already.
button.  It's done.  That could
be the style there being the
most popular of all the answers.
The correct answer is anything
but get computed style.  Here's
why.  browser starts off knowing
the layout of every element.
they need to know that stuff to
draw what you saw on the frame
before.  Translate X to 200
pixels meaning the browser's
calculations aren't up to date.
That isn't a problem because
the browser recomputes
everything to update the
rendering.  If we call get
bounding clients in a width or
text, they will to recalculate
it synchronously in order to
give you the correct answer.
you ask for the width of an
element, the browser has to
figure out what changed and then
and only then does it give you
the answer.  All the correct
answers cause that to happen.
The most surprising one is in a
text.  In a text it has a layout
dependency because it won't
give you the text of the inner
elements and has dependencies on
line layout as well.  Five five
JAKE ARCHIBALD:  Five the
problem is they have heavyweight
options.  Not per frame in the
previous example.  Since they
scale, they push it back.  You
have to wait a few milliseconds.
he'd like to do is avoid
calculating layout if possible,
which we can do with get
computed style.  You might have
noticed that wasn't one of the
correct answers, and that's
because things are ever so
slightly nuanced here.  You
might think get computer style
captures the styles.  No,
whether it's cold, but it's not.
if you do the styles before
checking a property. style
subject, you get the second
value and not the first.  This
blew my mind first.  The styles
aren't computes when you call
the big get computer styles
function, they're computed when
you access one of the properties
of the object it returns.  So
work around this weirdness, you
have get computer style and
access one of the properties
like transform.  In the question
we didn't transform it.  This
is a nice and imperative API to
do animations and make use of
compositng and everything.
animations, not great support
out there.  It's basically
partial SAPT in Chrome and
Firefox.  It's not in Edge or
Safari.  While it is an option,
you probably use get computed
style for the time being.  With
both network and rendering
people hopefully fairly happy,
but it isn't over  Let's bring
on the the quick fire round, the
silly questions that didn't fit
into the narrative of the talk
anyway.  Pretty much.  first one
of these.  Ready?  go.  Quick
fire is quick.  happens with
foo?
Get an answer in quickly.  We
have one answer that's popular.
Take a guess because we close
the question in three, two, one.
called quick fire for a
reason.  200 pixels is the most
popular answer there.  According
to the CSS spec, here we go.
al GOE HIMENT fight is to figure
out the tentative height.  If
it's bigger reduce it.  A bit
smaller than min height, grow
it.   no idea what you said.  It
means minimum high always wins.
Another quick fire question.
This is my favorite.  After
running this code, which of the
following is set to 1?  We have
the 8 array and we set a bunch
of items there to one.
suggestion is one or more may
not work.  an answer in quickly.
Big thanks to the team.  We
didn't know anything about it.
Judging by the spread of
answers, you know nothing about
it.  It's fine.  We're all
friends here.  great.  We're
locking it in in three, two,
one.  There we go.
Okay.  Who knows.  The correct
answers, though, here they come
from the server, which is
getting slow.  There we go.  1.9
and 1 point north.    pretty
weird.  When you do this kind of
thing and assign with a string,
JavaScript needs to solve if
you prescribe to a property of
the product or an array.  It's
treated like array and so is
strings if it's a representation
of a number.  When I first
heard that, I had no idea that
meant.  What is this about?  .9
is not an key no, ma'am Cal
representation.   will treat it
as a property assignment and
that's fine.  Say for 1.0.  1.1
is the representation of 1.1 so
JS treats it as a number.  It
trials to assign to the 1.1 item
of the array.  It's silently
acknowledged.  Why TROE an
error.  The same for 1.2 and
same kind of deal.   to the last
question.  We're going to move
on if any clicker continues to
work.  That makes me happier. at
the ready.  Here we go.  Five
how many elements are created?
Plus equal, plus equal, plus
equal.  How many elements does
it create.  Let's see how
they're voting.  Quick firing.
We have two strong answers and
two people are DMISive.  We
close in three, two, one.  We
are closed.  So we saw 4 and 1
are the most popular answers of
the room.  The correct answer,
of course,
Why is this, then?  When you
use plus equals and it's
equivalent.  It's a read and
write.  So if we expand this out
further, we create 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 elements.
There you go.  There you go.
to, you can insert HTML which is
ancient.  Thank you, Internet
Explore for her R the API.
We'll do the final question of
the whole quiz now.  might be my
favorite, this one.  Given this
chunk of HTML, which resources
are requested?  We've got an
image of a source and excellent
and a script of a source and the
preload.  It's select many, so
select all that you think apply.
One, two, three, and four.
Let's see the answers.  A real
spread here.  kind of confident.
Wow. anyone else see that?  a
large amount of bird mess that
just landed right in front of
us.  That is incredible
incredible.  Someone didn't pick
the right answer in the last
round.  Fair enough.  Okay.  I'm
going to step back a little
bit. going to close the question
in three,
it goes.  So a sort of spread
there of the answers.   ones
actually are requested.  so
good.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:  It is just
one.  I don't know how many
spotted what was going on here.
Even though it's an IMADE image
it's a AMD image, so this
downloads.  This uses script, so
the browser just ignores it and
doesn't download. like that
one.  Have you noticed that that
code highlight has all but
gone.  Why has it changed?  In
HTML script elements cannot be
self-closing. doesn't work.  You
have to close scripts with a
proper closing script tag.
The browser are those two
LIFRNG  link elements in
JavaScript and throw an error.
Sorry, not sorry.   sorry.  This
is it.  The moment we have been
waiting almost 45 minutes for.
are the winners of the mouse
pad?  Let's find out.  Oh.
Betts.  Congratulations.  All
three of you have won the mouse
pad.  A big round of applause to
the three winners.  this
session, find us and come to the
front with our phone and prove
you did get that score.  BIG WEB
QUIZ has a detail behind the
questions we asked today.  With
that, it's been a pleasure and a
blast.  so much for playing
along.  Thank you,
Applause )